mi-février le Parlement espagnol a
adopté une loi créant un congé menstruel
pour les femmes souffrant de règles
douloureuses nous nous demanderons si
cela peut constituer une piste de
solution alors que certaines craignent
les risques de discrimination qui
pourraient en découler et quelles autres
aménagement des postes de travail sont
envisagables deuxième problématique les
troubles de la fertilité et les parcours
d'assistance médicale à la procréation
nous savons que l'exposition à certains
produits chimiques a des conséquences
sur la fertilité et sur l'état de santé
de l'enfant à naître comme évoqué
notamment par le docteur Rollin lors de
notre précédente table ronde se pose
donc la question des aménagements
possibles pour limiter l'exposition
des femmes en âge de procréer nous nous
intéresserons également aux mesures
facilitant les parcours de PMA des
femmes en activité professionnelle en
Suisse des autorisations d'absence
rémunérées prévues par le Code du
travail enfin nous nous pencherons sur
le sujet de la ménopause et du
vieillissement hormonal qui peuvent
perturber l'activité professionnelle en
entraînant notamment des changements
cardiovasculaires une diminution de la
densité
osseuse des bouffées de chaleur et des
troubles du sommeil de la mémoire et de
la concentration nos homologues de la
Chambre des communes britanniques ont
publié en juillet 2022 un rapport sur la
ménopause en milieu professionnel qui
plaidait pour que ce sujet soit pris en
compte au même titre que la maternité
dans les entreprises et cesse d'être une
cause de stigmatisation et de
discrimination
alors que ce sujet reste largement tabou
aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail
comme dans la société en général
l'Angleterre apparaît comme précurseur
elle a adopté à l'été 2022 une stratégie
pour la santé des femmes ce dont la
France et des pourvu et il y a inclus la
ménopause et le bien-être au travail des
femmes en situation de ménopause afin
d'étudier ces différentes problématiques
et les solutions d'aménagement pour y
répondre nous accueillons ce matin
Valérie lorbat des planches
co-fondatrice et présidente de la
Fondation pour la recherche sur
l'endométriose
Nathalie Massin endocrinologue est
responsable du centre d'assistance à la
procréation au centre hospitalier
intercommunal de Créteil Virginie Riot
co-fondatrice du collectif banque
association de patients de l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et de
personnes infertiles qui est connectée
en visio-conférence
Brigitte le tombe gynécologue médical
praticien hospitalier au CHRU de Lille
et membre du bureau du groupe d'études
sur la ménopause
et le vieillissement hormonal
Rachel Saada avocate au barreau de Paris
qui pourra notamment nous parler de
l'application du Code du travail
s'agissant des aménagements possibles
pour les femmes en parcours de PMA
enceinte faisant face à une fausse
couche atteinte d'endométriose ou
toucher par la ménopause j'étais un peu
concentrée parce que les noms de famille
c'est toujours on évite de faire
j'espère d'avoir écorché aucun nom
mesdames que ce soit en visio ou en
présentiel ce matin donc bienvenue à
vous toutes mesdames je vais laisser
sans plus tard tarder la parole à
Valérie lorba des planches cofondatrice
et présidente de la Fondation pour la
recherche sur
l'endométriose à vous la parole madame
merci beaucoup merci merci pour cette
invitation bonjour à toutes bonjour
mesdames oui je vous remercie pour cette
invitation à parler de l'endométriose
qui est une maladie certes dont on parle
de plus en plus mais l'endométriose au
travail c'est un sujet qu'on aborde pas
pas encore et pas assez quand on pense à
la proportion de femmes atteintes vous
l'avez on parle de 10% de la population
probablement un peu plus 10% des femmes
probablement un peu plus et qui commence
souvent à l'âge des premières règles
avec des symptômes qui souvent on évoque
les douleurs de règles au moment des
règles en réalité son dessin des
symptômes qui peuvent s'élargir au-delà
du moment des règles qui peuvent devenir
quotidienne on parle aussi de disparus
de douleurs au moment des rapports mais
également de troubles de la fertilité
l'endométriose reste la première cause
de d'infertilité et puis aussi on en
parle moins de douleurs digestives de
douleurs
urinaires de douleurs lombaires de
douleurs dans les jambes donc vraiment
de douleurs qui s'étendent bien au-delà
de la région pelvy périnéale quand on
parle sévérité on parle souvent
médicalement des formes dans trios
profondes en réalité et donc on les
évoque plutôt aux alentours de 15-20% ce
qui concerne plutôt des actes
chirurgicaux en réalité on devrait
associer c'est déjà une des choses qu'on
devrait changer je pense qu'on devrait
déjà associer plutôt les sévère aux
symptômes et en fait à la qualité de vie
des femmes en réalité vraiment à
l'intensité des douleurs qu'elle
provoque il y a une étude d'une
sociologue qui a été faite à l'ICE
Romero qui a interrogé des femmes qui
évaluent à peu près 30% de femmes qui
ont des formes sévères de la maladie en
tout cas dans leur vie la prise en
charge de l'endométriose aujourd'hui en
première intention et de plus en plus
enfin on adresse les douleurs et donc
effectivement la première intention
c'est souvent un traitement hormonal qui
vise à une aménorrhée pour stopper les
règles qui stoppent l'évolution de la
maladie dans la dans la plupart des cas
ainsi que les douleurs il y a évidemment
les antalgiques les antidouleurs et puis
il y a aussi de façon plus générale
parce que j'allais dire on dit souvent
qu'il y a autant d'endométriose que de
femmes qui ont de l'endométriose une
prise en charge multidisciplinaire qui
doit être adaptée à chaque cas et de
plus en plus on fait appel à d'autres
médecines complémentaires alors à la
fois selon les atteintes ça peut être
aussi de la gastro-entérologie de
l'urologie mais également de la
kinésithérapie de l'ostéopathie une
approche alimentaire de la gym douce il
est important de remettre les femmes en
mouvement pour éviter aussi les douleurs
donc il y a vraiment une prise en charge
qui est assez complexe finalement et qui
doit être étudiée au cas par cas
32% des problèmes digestifs pour 70% des
douleurs lombaires dans 66% des cas dans
les jambes également dans 45% des cas et
l'endométriose est souvent associée à
d'autres maladies comme la fibre myalgie
comme également des maladies
auto-immunes etc donc on voit que le
paysage est quand même assez assez
complexe et les conséquences sont
importantes donc on imagine bien que
dans le cadre du travail pour une femme
les douleurs évidemment ont un impact
dans la capacité à rester debout même
assise à garder une position elle est
fréquemment aux toilettes des choses que
les femmes n'ont pas envie d'avouer mais
malheureusement c'est leur quotidien
donc c'est vraiment très handicapant
dans le cadre du travail
on parle de la douleur mais on parle le
moins de la fatigue chronique puisque
c'est une maladie qui entraîne de la
fatigue chronique et qui a aussi cet
impact parce que les femmes sont
extrêmement fatiguées dans le cadre du
travail il y a une étude qui a été
publiée récemment au Canada qui montre
que les femmes qui se déclarentent
d'endométriose disent s'absenter du
travail pendant 17% du temps avoir une
diminution de leur capacité de travail
de 41% et un problème de productivité au
travail de plus de 46%. et ce chiffre
monte à 63% chez les femmes entre 30 et
40 ans là où elles sont j'allais dire le
plus productive où elles sont vraiment
en pleine évolution de carrière au final
à peu près une femme sur deux dit
qu'elle a été impactée dans sa carrière
à cause de l'endométriose je
mentionnerai également les parcours de
PMA puisque c'est un problème de
fertilité aussi dans certains cas qui
évidemment peut être problématique dans
le cadre du travail
alors quand on regarde les données en
fait en particulier en France on a très
peu de données les arrêts de travail en
tout cas moi je n'ai pas trouvé de
chiffres et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles la Fondation recherche
endométriose a décidé de mener des
enquêtes dans les entreprises pour avoir
enfin des chiffres et pour pouvoir
mettre aussi un inconfort et des coûts
également il faut regarder les deux
aspects évidemment ce que l'on sait dans
d'autres pays qui ont fait des études
c'est que la perte de travail et c'est
énorme et estimée à 11h par femme et par
semaine et quand on parle perte de
travail il faut vraiment penser à
l'absentéisme mais il faut aussi penser
aux présentéisme je l'ai dit fatigue
chronique donc les femmes elles viennent
quand même travailler quand elles ont
épuisé les jours d'arrêt maladie leurs
congés leur RTT elles viennent quand
même elles sont sous médicaments où
elles souffrent elles sont très
fatiguées et évidemment elles
reconnaissent elles-mêmes qu'elles ne
sont pas productives en plus elles
culpabilise donc il y a vraiment un
effet important et on considère selon
une dernière étude qui a été publiée en
Australie en 2022 que le coût est de 20
000 dollars
par femme et par an et que 84% de ce
coût est dû à la perte de productivité
de coût pour deux coups général pour la
société en fait y compris les
traitements etc
donc ce qu'on voit aussi c'est que
concernant l'absentéisme souvent les
l'absentéisme qui est lié à
l'endométriose c'est plutôt un
absentisme fréquent mais pas très long
et ce qui entraîne évidemment des pertes
financières pour les femmes puisqu'en
fait il y a des jours de carence et donc
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'elles hésitent
à s'absenter au-delà de l'impact et de
l'image qu'elles peuvent avoir dans
l'entreprise et donc c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les associations
de patientes ont militait pour la ld30
la mise en place de la ld30 de cette
maladie dans le cadre des ailes des 30
justement pour éviter ces problèmes de
jours de carence il faut vraiment avoir
à l'esprit que les femmes ont des coûts
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas pris en
charge par la sécurité sociale plus
l'absentéisme et donc la charge
financière pour les malades est
extrêmement importante
sur les femmes qui renoncent à
travailler en fait cette étude toujours
de la sociologue qui est quasiment la
seule étude qu'on est en France en fait
aujourd'hui montre que 25% des femmes
qui sont atteintes d'endométriose ont
renoncé à leur statut ou alors métier
donc vraiment un impact extrêmement
important pour s'adapter à leur maladie
et très souvent et je le vois dans tes
témoignages autour de nous finalement
s'installe quitte l'entreprise
s'installe comme on taux entrepreneur se
précarise donc au-delà du sujet de la
difficulté de carrière j'allais dire il
y a un vrai sujet de précarisation qui
n'est pas évalué aujourd'hui mais qui
est qui est extrêmement important
il y a d'ailleurs une étude qui a été
réalisée en Australie qui montre que 14%
des femmes disent qu'elles ont été
licenciées à cause de la maladie j'ai
moi-même eu un témoignage pas plus tard
qu'il y a deux jours qui étaient
extrêmement émouvant d'une femme qui a
été licenciée pendant son arrêt maladie
alors qu'elle avait annoncé son
entreprise quelle souffrait
d'endométriose un parcours épouvantable
et au moment où elle s'apprêtait à
reprendre et à se remettre dans le dans
le la perspective de reprendre son
travail 3 à 4 mois après en lui
annonçait sèchement qu'elle était
licenciée donc il y a vraiment un sujet
non elle est alors ce qui est compliqué
c'est qu'elle est totalement désemparée
en fait parce qu'elle est je pense
qu'elle est vraiment enfin c'est un coup
de massue pour elle elle s'attendait à
ce que l'entreprise l'accueillait à
nouveau parce que c'était préparé et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui elle est en
réflexion de savoir ce qu'elle va faire
en fait
ça c'est en France le cas que le
témoignage est en France le chiffre de
14% est en Australie parce que ça n'est
pas chiffré en France mais ce témoignage
est en France il est tout récent il m'a
vraiment marqué parce qu'on en parlait
aujourd'hui et je trouve que c'est
frappant donc ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
rare malheureusement
et en plus il faut savoir aussi c'est
que ces femmes souvent au-delà de la
précarisation elles sont isolées
l'endométriose conduit aussi un vrai
sujet d'isolement dans le couple aussi
et souvent les femmes sont seules donc
vous imaginez cette femme d'ailleurs qui
a 45 ans m'a dit je suis obligé de
demander à mes parents de m'aider parce
que je ne peux pas prendre en charge
tous mes frais et en plus maintenant
évidemment je suis au chômage donc sans
dresser un portrait noir malheureusement
ça existe c'est une réalité aujourd'hui
alors les solutions il y a évidemment
des adaptations possibles encore faut-il
en parler il y a des adaptations
possibles de poste l'étude d'Alice
romeriaux montre que 66% des femmes
qu'elle a interrogé disent qu'elles
l'ont annoncé dans leur entreprise et
pourtant seulement un quart d'entre
elles ont bénéficié d'aménagement de
poste donc il ne suffit pas de le dire
pour qu'il y ait des mesures qui soient
prises derrière
alors évidemment pour pouvoir prendre
des mesures il faut que le médecin du
travail soit engagé mais tout ne peut
pas reposer sur le médecin du travail et
pour que le médecin du travail conseille
des aménagements de poste et recommande
des aménagements de poste encore faut-il
qu'il soit formés aujourd'hui il y a un
défaut de formation des professionnels
de santé en particulier des médecins du
travail et on a eu plusieurs sociétés
employant des médecins du travail qui
nous ont demandé d'ailleurs de faire de
la sensibilisation auprès des médecins
du travail qui sont peu informés du
sujet
d'autre part il faut aussi pour que les
femmes et pour libérer la parole qui est
une véritable culture bienveillante de
l'entreprise ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas en général les gens se disent
qu'est-ce qu'elle a celle-là elle est
encore absente sans savoir sans se poser
de questions finalement des raisons pour
lesquelles elle est elle est absente
alors le volet du plan national
endométriose prend ce sujet il y a un
vrai sujet endométriose et travail donc
il est urgent et la première des choses
et mon message c'est vraiment
d'appliquer ce volet endométriose et
travail qui est dans la stratégie
nationale les femmes qui ont recours aux
mi-temps thérapeutiques puisqu'on peut
avoir un mi-temps thérapeutique
évidemment je n'ai pas de chiffres
aujourd'hui de même que la
reconnaissance RQTH je pense qu'il y a
des femmes alors ça c'est très
qualitatif mais il y a des femmes qui me
disent moi je n'ai pas envie de demander
une reconnaissance RQTH parce qu'elles
sont voilà cette notion travailleur
handicapé c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile pour elle et puis elles ont
l'impression que ça ça fasse voir que ça
va savoir donc ça reste encore très très
tabou
le recours au télétravail est une option
et elle disait même qu'elles ont recours
au télétravail encore faut-il qu'il soit
flexible parce qu'il y a des entreprises
où il est imposé il y a certains jours
imposés finalement ça ne correspond pas
aux épisodes de douleur des femmes mais
ça n'est évidemment pas la seule
solution en tout cas il y a une vraie
flexibilité à la fois du temps de
travail aussi des horaires de travail
qui peut aider les femmes et de
l'utilisation du télétravail
concernant le congé menstruel
effectivement qui a été
approuvé en Espagne alors c'est une
question qui est extrêmement compliquée
quant à moi je pense que elle elle ouvre
un débat assez vaste alors elle a
l'avantage de d'enlever ce tabou et de
libérer la parole autour des règles dans
l'entreprise que je trouve extrêmement
positif en revanche j'ai toujours peur
d'annonces marketing des entreprises
et puis je pense que l'endométriose
comme d'autres pathologies de femmes
féminine est une vraie pathologie et que
ça doit aller bien au-delà d'un congé
menstruel par ailleurs je le disais il
faut une culture bienveillante dans
l'entreprise et s'il n'y a pas de
culture bienveillante le congé menstruel
risque d'être contre-productif donc ça
ne peut pas être la seule mesure
j'allais dire même si on doit la
considérer
alors est-ce que la problématique de
l'endométriose aujourd'hui est reconnue
par les employeurs je dirais pas du tout
c'est un véritable angle mort et je
pense que les entreprises même
aujourd'hui n'imaginent pas la perte de
productivité quand je parlais de ces 11
heures par semaine et par femme je pense
qu'ils entreprises sont pas du tout
conscientes de ça et il y a un sondage
qui a été réalisé qui n'est pas encore
publié mais qui dit que 20% des gens
interrogés considèrent qu'elle n'est pas
prise en compte et que 61% ne savent pas
donc je pense qu'on peut dire qu'à peu
près 80% des gens en réalité ne voient
rien se passer dans leur entreprise donc
c'est vraiment un sujet aujourd'hui qui
est quasiment inexistant et il est
inexistant d'autant plus que les femmes
ne prennent pas la parole puisqu'en fait
elles sont nombreuses à dire et plus
d'un tiers déclare qu'elles viennent au
travail malgré des douleurs
handicapantes donc il y a aussi cette
pression très forte que les que les
femmes subissent
des initiatives aujourd'hui sur
l'endométriose je n'en connais pas je
connais des entreprises qui demandent
des sensibilisations mais j'allais dire
il y a un vrai risque aujourd'hui c'est
à dire
sensibiliser ses biens et c'est une
première étape mais ça n'est pas
suffisant parce que ça ouvre des
attentes de la part des femmes qui sont
atteintes aujourd'hui sans apporter de
solution donc je pense que c'est un une
partie du dispositif mais ça n'est pas
suffisant il y a certaines entreprises
comme le groupe M6 par exemple qui
travaille beaucoup sur la RQTH et qui
dans le cadre de la RQTH informe les
salariés et notamment souvent d'ailleurs
au mois de mars informe les femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose qu'elles
peuvent bénéficier d'une reconnaissance
travailleur handicapée et dans ce cadre
là mettent en place un supplément de
soutien mutuel des remboursements de
frais de taxi quand les gens sont
vraiment vraiment des douleurs donc il y
a des jours de congés supplémentaires
donc il y a des mesures qui sont prises
mais uniquement quand la personne est
reconnue travailleur handicapé après il
y a des petites entreprises aujourd'hui
en France qui mettent en place le congé
menstruel mais en tout cas il n'y a rien
qui soit fait spécifiquement
en termes de je n'ai pas regardé l'heure
en termes de recommandation pour
améliorer les la situation
professionnelle encore une fois je pense
que les choses sont déjà écrites dans le
dans le volet
endométriose et travail de la stratégie
nationale aujourd'hui on ne voit pas les
applications encore de cette stratégie
qui pourtant était vraiment importantes
donc je pense que l'urgence c'est
vraiment ça
et puis je pense qu'il faut aussi
stimuler les entreprises les inciter à
prendre des mesures il était mentionné
la mise en place d'un label pour les
entreprises comme ça a été fait sur le
plan emploi et cancer en fait et je
pense que ça permettra à inciter les
entreprises et a aussi reconnaître les
entreprises qui mettront en place des
mesures donc ça c'est important et
d'ailleurs donc la Fondation que je
préside la Fondation recherche
endométriose en fait nous avons monté un
projet qui répond exactement aux axes de
la stratégie nationale avec une
sensibilisation dans les entreprises une
enquête quantitative anonyme pour
libérer la parole parce que c'est là
aussi il faut absolument anonymiser les
données et pour que les entreprises
découvrent finalement quel est l'ampleur
du phénomène quantitativement et
qualitativement c'est à dire quel type
de symptômes quel impact dans le cadre
du travail et surtout quelle solution ma
conviction c'est que les solutions
doivent partir des femmes qui souffrent
et ne pas être calé sur Coller j'allais
dire sur sur une problématique parce que
les femmes elles ont des stratégies
aujourd'hui elles utilisent des
dispositifs d'entreprises et finalement
il conviendrait de les mettre en valeur
et de les généraliser pour que toutes
les femmes puissent en bénéficier et
puis derrière un accompagnement
évidemment des entreprises dans la mise
en place et notamment avec des experts
alors sur les exemples qu'on pourrait
mentionner on a parlé de la flexibilité
du temps de travail des horaires de
travail aussi les femmes souvent ont du
mal j'allais dire à démarrer le matin si
elle pouvait arriver plus tard sans
êtreostisée ça pourrait être une une des
solutions les jours de télétravail
choisis et non imposées des heures
peut-être d'absence rémunérée pour
rendez-vous médicaux il y a aussi
quelque chose qui se met en place de
plus en plus qui sont des modules
d'éducation thérapeutique patiente sur
l'endométriose ça dure deux jours ça
n'est pas payé aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
pris en charge une entreprise pourrait
très bien payer les jours c'est ce sont
des jours de formation finalement pour
les patients ça pourrait être une mesure
intéressante des entretiens réguliers du
mentorat aussi on sait que c'est
compliqué pour les femmes d'évoluer dans
les entreprises du mentorat pour
accompagner les femmes dans leur
parcours de carrière à certains moments
peut-être elles vont devoir prendre un
petit peu de recul se mettre en mi-temps
thérapeutique mais reprendre le cours de
leur carrière quand ça va mieux elles
doivent être accompagnées et c'est le
rôle aussi du management encore une fois
ça ne peut pas être que le médecin du
travail qui prend cela en charge des
packs spécifiques mutuelles il y a des
mutuelles aujourd'hui qui commencent à
avoir des actions autour de
l'endométriose et puis des choses plus
anecdotiques mais néanmoins importantes
l'alimentation à un rôle important dans
la composante inflammatoire de la
maladie et les femmes qui suivent un
régime anti-inflammatoire bah elle
s'isole aussi parce qu'elles viennent
avec leur doggy bag et puis elle mange
toute seule parce que dans les
restaurants d'entreprises en fait ça
n'est pas prévu donc il pourrait y avoir
des actions qui sont assez simples
finalement et éducatives aussi donc en
fait on s'aperçoit que c'est tout un
ensemble de mesures qui pourraient être
prises dans les entreprises je pense
même que ces critères devraient être
intégrés dans les critères d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes dans les
entreprises à un moment il faut vraiment
que ce soit marqué que ce soit évident
pour accompagner ces femmes donc il y a
urgence et je pense qu'il y a une
urgence pour vraiment quelque chose qui
serait un contrat gagnant-gagnant encore
une fois les entreprises il y a une
vraie perte de productivité des femmes
aujourd'hui qui qui renoncent à leur
carrière on parle de l'impact dans le
cadre du travail mais ça commence dès
les études il y a plein de jeunes filles
qui ne peuvent pas suivre d'études
supérieures à cause de la maladie il y a
des femmes qui qui renoncent vraiment à
leurs rêves de carrière il y a des
femmes qui ne peuvent pas adapter leur
poste de travail parce que quand on est
dans une usine on peut pas s'asseoir et
un moment il faut former les femmes pour
qu'elles puissent avoir d'autres postes
dans l'entreprise donc il est urgent
vraiment d'intervenir maintenant de
mettre en place des mesures je pense que
c'est le moment et je pense que les
femmes sont prêtes et je dirais aussi
que les jeunes générations sont d'autant
plus prêtes à parler de la maladie à
combattre les tabous et elles attendent
beaucoup plus des entreprises
aujourd'hui les jeunes générations sont
beaucoup plus exigeantes que les
entreprises donc je pense que c'est une
prise de conscience aussi que pour
attirer les jeunes et les maintenir dans
une entreprise il est temps de prendre
des mesures
voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente pour
cette exposée qui dresse une situation
complète et qui fait aussi place à des
solutions que vous avez développé donc
je vais tout de suite passer la parole à
Nathalie Massin donc endocrinologue et
responsable du centre d'assistance
médicale à la procréation au centre
hospitalier intercommunal de Créteil à
vous madame madame merci Madame les
rapporteurs merci de pouvoir écouter ce
matin donc sur le sujet des troubles de
la fertilité du parcours en MP et de
l'implication dans la vie
professionnelle des femmes donc juste
pour rappel l'infertilité touche 15% des
couples en âge de procréé qui sont aussi
les couples en vie active et
professionnelle et cette proportion
d'infertilité ne cesse de progresser en
rapport avec le retard de l'âge à la
maternité qu'on voit très clairement et
même si la moitié des causes
d'infertilité sont d'origine masculine
pour autant c'est le poids uniquement
sur les femmes par rapport au traitement
d'AMP et puis on peut rajouter également
les femmes aujourd'hui qui doivent
accéder à l'AMP quand elles sont en
couple de femmes et de femmes seules
puisque la loi lise autorise aujourd'hui
pour un projet parental donc c'est
difficile de généraliser une multitude
situation singulière dont dépend de les
causes l'infertilité la vie
professionnelle la vie du couple mais je
crois si on veut synthétiser on peut
considérer qu'il y a vraiment trois
problèmes majeurs dans la question de
l'infertilité et du travail de la femme
donc le premier vous l'avez évoqué
madame la Présidente c'est l'exposition
au toxique et vous avez eu une audition
spécifique à ce sujet le deuxième c'est
l'exposition à des rides de travail
complexes impactant la qualité de vie et
en particulier la qualité du sommeil et
de l'alimentation comme par exemple le
travail de nuit les navigants et ça ça
va entraîner des perturbations
hormonales en particulier au niveau de
la mélatonine et c'est perturbations
peuvent entraîner les troubles du sigle
des troubles de l'ovulation donc une
absence de possibilité de grossesse
d'une part et d'autre part également des
maladies cardiovasculaires de l'obésité
du diabète qui elle aussi vont impacter
sur sur la fertilité mais les troubles
du sommeil peuvent également entraîner
une diminution significative des chances
de grossesse il y a une étude très
récente qui vient d'être publiée sur
plus de 8000 femmes qui montrent que en
fécondation in vitro donc quand on est
déjà dans un parcours d'ampac avancé et
bien les chances de conception sont
significativement diminuées de 5% pour
les femmes qui ont des troubles du
sommeil donc c'est quand même assez
important puisque là on parle de de
chances de grossesse à chaque tentative
qui sont de l'ordre de 30%. donc 5% ça
fait quand même une grosse différence
donc ce manque de sommeil est une vraie
une vraie problématique il est également
souvent responsable de dépression qui va
aggraver la qualité de vie pour pour les
femmes qui sont en parcours AMD et le
troisième point donc c'est les
contraintes qui sont liées au traitement
le parcours en assistance médicale à la
procréation c'est un mot assez guerrier
mais il utiliser à juste titre et c'est
sur ça que je vais insister si les deux
premiers points relèvent d'une
adaptation du poste de travail ou de
l'environnement du travail lors de la
période péri conceptionnelle qui
comprend donc les deux à trois mois
avant le projet de conception puisque 2
à 3 mois c'est le temps qu'il faut pour
un renouvellement des spermatozoïdes
comme des ovocytes donc il faut tenir
compte de cette période
préconceptionnelle dans l'exposition au
toxique donc là ça nécessite et bien des
adaptations des aménagements du poste de
travail qui sont pas toujours possible
malheureusement comme leur a des
planches la la évoqué et également qui
sont stigmatisants alors je vais
insister sur les contraintes du parcours
en AMP la première chose qu'il faut
avoir bien conscience de ce que là
représente pour les femmes en termes de
durée du parcours et d'absence
nécessaire et donc c'est ça qui va
altérer très significativement la
qualité de vie en général mais également
les relations du couple les relations
sociales et la qualité du travail
donc pour donner une idée précise du
temps il y a une étude qui a été
réalisée récemment qui s'appelle l'étude
mildrisme qui est publiée par Madame
Domart et donc qui rapporte sur une
enquête qui a été réalisée en ligne
début 2019 sur 2000 femmes et leur
partenaires donc 200 couples français
qui montrent donc la longueur de ce
parcours donc pour vous donner une idée
c'est quand même 7,7 années en moyenne
de parcours en assistance médicale à la
procréation donc il faut vraiment tenir
compte de ça et si on divise en trois
étapes donc ça c'est des chiffres en
France il y a trois années et demi de
temps passé à des essais de conception
naturelle avant que le diagnostic
d'infertilité soit passé et donc
l'impact que ça a tous ces échecs sur la
santé de la femme ensuite à proprement
parler il y a deux ans de temps
d'exploration d'analyse avant de pouvoir
débuter les traitements d'AMP et après
en moyenne deux ans deux
de durée de traitement en soi avant
d'obtenir une conception et après il y a
le temps de la maternité
et donc dans cette même étude les trois
principaux freins qui ont été identifiés
à la réalisation d'un traitement d'AMP
c'est-à-dire finalement vouloir
poursuivre son projet de conception à
travers un traitement c'est le coût le
temps investi et la charge émotionnelle
et le coût est présent à leur même qu'il
y a une prise en charge à 100% en France
parce que c'est pas seulement
inconfinancier mais c'est aussi ce coup
sur le sur le temps et le retentissement
sur sur la vie
la deuxième partie donc en dehors de ce
temps long c'est d'avoir une idée
précise de ce que ça implique en terme
d'absence nécessaire et donc il faut
additionner tous les rendez-vous qui
vont pouvoir mener à un traitement et
donc dans le cadre du bilan de
l'infertilité pour le bilan initial il
faut prévoir en général une dizaine de
rendez-vous avant qu'on puisse lancer un
traitement il faut savoir que ces
rendez-vous vont dépendre la date des
règles des femmes et donc laisser peu de
contrôle finalement dans l'organisation
personnelle et professionnelle d'une
part et d'autre part
ils vont être souvent imprévisibles et
rapidement les femmes dont voilà dans
l'espace de 2-3 jours de voir organiser
leur planning pour suivre ces examens
d'une part et d'autre part c'est souvent
sur des lieux différents avec des femmes
qui ont des accès très difficiles en
particulier en zone rurale 12% des
femmes mettent plus de deux heures pour
pouvoir accéder à leur centre d'AMP et
on regarde au total 30% des femmes à peu
près on leur centre d'AMP qui est à plus
d'une heure de leur lieu de travail ou
de leur domicile donc ça c'est pour au
départ le bilan initial et après pour
chaque tentative de traitement il va y
avoir des rendez-vous supplémentaires
donc par exemple pour une insémination
intra-utérine qui est la première ligne
de traitement en assistance médicale à
la procréation quand je dirais qu'il y a
une infertilité qui est peu sévère c'est
au moins trois rendez-vous qui doivent
être réalisés sur une période de 7 à 10
jours et qui sont déterminés d'un au
dernier moment quand les règles arrivent
et pour une tentative de fécondation in
vitro donc c'est c'est l'étape au dessus
et bien dans ces cas là c'est une
dizaine de rendez-vous qui sont répartis
sur une quinzaine de jours avec une
intervention chirurgicale etc donc c'est
quand même extrêmement lourd pour les
pour les femmes
en plus de cette difficulté d'accès donc
si on veut résumer le parcours AMP on
voit bien qu'il y a des absences qui
doivent être très fréquentes qui sont
proprogrammables dont la dérivée va
dépendre de l'accessibilité des centres
et puis sur une longue période mais une
longue période de temps qui est
imprévisible c'est-à-dire que là où il y
a en moyenne 7,7 années de parcours et
bien sûr il va y avoir des parcours très
courts et puis il va y avoir des
parcours très longs parfois jusqu'à une
quinzaine d'années et donc il y a un
double retentissement du travail sur les
traitements mais également des
traitements sur le travail comme pour
l'endométriose et donc assez contraintes
il faut associer les troubles physiques
et psychologiques liés à l'infertilité
essentiellement porté par les femmes que
je vais pas développer ici alors
concernant les absences qui sont
autorisées dans le cadre de la loi il
faut savoir de mon expérience qui a
elles ne sont pas systématiquement pas
utiliser par les femmes tout d'abord
parce que ça oblige à déclarer à
l'employeur l'infertilité et donc un
projet de conception et on sait que ça
ça peut être stigmatisant dans l'autre
prise donc ça c'est vraiment un problème
et puis ça fait déclarer aussi
l'infertilité et puis les échecs
c'est-à-dire quand le parcours dur non
seulement il y a la peine des échecs
mais il y a aussi
ses échecs qui sont sur la place
publique puisque le parcours doit
persister donc c'est une double peine
alors
dans les pistes de proposition pour
faciliter donc la vie professionnelle
dans le cadre de la prise en charge en
AMP j'ai essayé de différencier trois
ordres donc un premier ordre qui est
l'adaptation des absences au travail
liées à l'AMP dans le cadre du 100%
infertilité donc adapter ce qui existe
déjà dans dans la loi donc par exemple
en supprimant le motif d'infertilité
pour les absences dans le cadre de la
loi en signifiant que ce sont uniquement
des absences qui sont liées à une
pathologie à 100% qui pourrait convenir
pour d'autres pathologies chroniques
donc ça évite cette première
stigmatisation ensuite ça a déjà été
évoqué donc facilité l'accès au travail
au télétravail flexible toujours pareil
dans le cas d'une pathologie à 100% et
puis supprimer le délai de carence pour
les arrêts de travail d'une journée
puisque parfois pour multiplier les
rendez-vous on va essayer de les
regrouper sur une journée et c'est très
compliqué de concilier ça au travail et
s'il y a un arrêt de travail qui est
fait pour une journée et bien c'est une
pénalité pour la fiche de salaire pour
pour la femme donc ça ça pourrait
faciliter le fait de regrouper les
rendez-vous ensuite il y a une inégalité
puisque c'est un parcours de couple et
donc les hommes aujourd'hui sont de plus
en plus chouettes de plus en plus
investir dans
parcours ce qui est une excellente chose
parce qu'il constitue un soutien le
premier soutien pour pour les femmes et
aujourd'hui la loi est inégale parce que
les hommes n'ont droit qu'à trois
absences alors que les femmes ont droit
à plusieurs absences et je pense que
redonner donner les mêmes absences aux
hommes qu'aux femmes ça permet vraiment
de d'avoir une démarche de couple
d'avoir ce soutien auprès des femmes et
puis également pour faciliter la vie des
femmes par exemple il y a certaines
femmes qui ne conduisent pas ou qui
n'ont pas l'automobile c'est l'homme qui
a l'automobile et donc elles sont
contraintes de longues heures de
transport pour accéder au centre d'AMP
alors que le conjoint pourrait les
accompagner
et puis alors
envisager des absences
programmées un peu prolongé peut-être
dans le cadre de congé infertilité ou de
congé Fives je ne sais pas exactement
comment ça ça peut s'articuler sans bien
sûr retentissement sur sur la carrière
donc ça c'est le premier volet c'est
travailler sur ce qui existe déjà dans
dans la loi mais mais l'adapter pour que
l'ensemble des femmes sont le prennent
parce que c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
j'ai rémunérer rémunérer pas dans le
cadre de la loi travail qui existe
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui ce qui est X
n'est pas pris par l'ensemble des
couples je dirais que ça représente
moins de 50% des femmes qui déclarent à
leur employeur être un parcours
infertilité et donc avoir ses absences
rémunérées autorisées
le deuxième volet c'est d'encourager la
prévention via la médecine du travail je
pense que c'est vraiment extrêmement
important effectivement les médecins du
travail sont peu formés à l'information
sur la physiologie de la reproduction et
à l'exposition au toxique et à
l'exposition surtout au rythme de
travail contraignant et donc cette
information elle est pour moi centrale
sans qui pour autant y est une attitude
pro nataliste des médecins du travail
puisque chacun doit décider s'il
souhaite une maternité ou pas mais
d'être un support d'information au cours
des visites sur le temps qui passe et
les chances de grossesse qui peuvent
diminuer d'une part et d'autre part
aussi rappeler que quand il y a un
projet fertilité que si celui-ci
n'aboutit pas au bout de 6 mois qu'il y
a une nécessité de consulter rapidement
pourquoi parce que ce temps qu'on perd
avant d'aller consulter et de faire le
bilan c'est du retard dans la prise en
charge et donc c'est une augmentation du
délai des parcours puisque la fertilité
diminue avec l'âge et donc là il y a
vraiment je pense un rôle chose qui
pourrait être joué par les médecins du
travail pour favoriser une prise en
charge plus plus rapide et aussi
intégrer au travail de l'entreprise et
puis le troisième volet je pense qu'il
faut pas oublier non plus que les
professionnels sont très importants en
AMP et pourraient essayer de s'adapter
un peu mieux à la vie professionnelle
des femmes
donc par exemple proposer des
organisations de soins qui limitent les
déplacements donc favoriser des
rendez-vous multiples sur une courte
période pour les bilans d'exploration
avant traitement favoriser également la
téléconsultation pour avoir et que la
femme est puisse avoir un espace de
téléconsultation au travail puisque
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
il y a beaucoup de rendez-vous qui
nécessitent pas un examen physique et
donc la téléconsultation a une vraie
place et puis donc essayez de programmer
dans la mesure du possible les
traitements pour que les femmes puissent
s'organiser en termes professionnels
avec leur entreprise sur sur ces
absences et donc bon bah comme pour tous
je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir une
incitation des professionnels à
organiser ces rendez-vous avec
robaleration de certains actes quand ils
sont couplés par exemple alors que c'est
aujourd'hui l'inverse c'est-à-dire quand
on fait deux actes sur un même
rendez-vous le deuxième acte et côté à
50% donc il y a entre guillemets une
perte a gagné pour les médecins et donc
ça n'est pas du tout stimulant pour
regrouper les rendez-vous voilà et puis
je pense que c'est très important comme
ça a été dit par Madame Laure des
planches d'écouter vraiment ce qu'on à
nous dire les patients puisque c'est
c'est eux qui sont en première ligne et
qui ont mis en place des stratégies
justement pour pouvoir maintenir une
bonne qualité de vie au travail en tout
cas dans la dans la mesure du possible
voilà je vous remercie pour votre écoute
et bien merci beaucoup madame donc pour
cette exposition c'est vrai que dans les
différents exposés on a une situation
des propositions donc je pense que les
rapporteurs déjà sont tout à fait
attentifs aux pistes que vous avez déjà
ouvertes donc je vais laisser la parole
maintenant en visio-conférence donc à
Madame Virginie Riot confondatrice du
collectif bande et elle va justement
nous livrer des témoignages de patientes
qui ont eu à concilier travail et
parcours de PMA et donc qui auront été
forcément confrontés j'imagine à des
difficultés pour faire appliquer le code
du travail et également nous faire part
de préconisations sur la base de ces
témoignages à vous madame
oui bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez
bien tout à fait alors je vous remercie
madame ma présidente et mesdames les
sénatrices nous permettent de parler de
ce sujet qui est un sujet très important
pour notre association qui notre
association qui fête aujourd'hui enfin
cette année 2023 c'est 10 ans donc on a
quand on a créé l'association en 2013 un
des premiers dossiers sur lequel on a
travaillé c'est justement sur cette
articulation entre l'AMP et le travail
donc c'est un ça a constitué une des
parties importantes de notre manifeste
donc dans lequel on faisait des constats
et des propositions
2013 c'est aussi l'année où on a
rencontré Madame Herzog qui est
sociologue à Caen et qui justement
commençait sa thèse sur ce sujet de
l'articulation entre l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et la vie
professionnelle qu'elle avait intitulé
Le travail invisible des femmes
donc en 2015 quand la loi santé a été
discutée nous évidemment nous avions
fait des constats et des propositions
qu'on avait soumis au parlementaire et
il y avait eu une très très forte
mobilisation de nos adhérents sur ce
sujet parce qu'à l'époque les gens
devaient s'arranger poser des congés
essayer de bidouiller des choses mentir
à leur employeur enfin les gens quand je
dis les gens c'est les femmes et les
hommes mais c'était généralement les
femmes qui étaient dans cette situation
là devaient bidouiller et pour nous
c'était pas acceptable donc évidemment
les à l'époque en 2015 les sénateurs
avaient ouvert la voie en proposant un
amendement qui avait été retenu dans la
loi et nous de notre côté on avait pu à
la suite de ça proposait des amendements
qui ont été retenus donc et qui ont
inclus les hommes dans les autorisations
d'absence pour trois rendez-vous et
aussi avec quelque chose qui était très
important pour chaque protocole parce
que comme l'a dit Madame Nathalie Massin
on a la prise en charge en France en AMP
et loin d'être une quelque chose qui
fonctionne à 100% et il y a beaucoup de
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont obligés
de recommencer plusieurs tentatives et
donc ça ça nécessite des temps d'absence
sur plusieurs années qui sont très
impactant pour la vie privée des gens
pour la vie professionnelle
donc cette cette loi enfin cet article
87 dans la loi santé a été promulgué en
janvier 2016 à partir de là nous on a eu
un travail énorme en 2016 2017 et 2018
d'informations de conseils de soutien
auprès des salariés aussi auprès des
syndicats parce que les choses se
mettaient en place donc on a beaucoup
travaillé avec les syndicats il y a donc
en 2016 aussi les autorisations
d'absence qui ont été accordées à la
fonction aux agents de la fonction
publique donc là ça nécessitait encore
tout un tas d'aménagements un besoin
d'informations de communication
il reste il y a des choses qui restaient
un peu compliquées à gérer dans le
quotidien en fait des salariés c'est la
question des temps de transport qui
reste quelque chose de flou et qui reste
quelque chose aujourd'hui encore sur
lequel les employeurs jouent en disant
et encore il y a pas longtemps j'étais
au téléphone avec un monsieur pour qui
était en parcours avec sa femme qui son
employeur lui disait non non vous n'avez
pas le droit le droit du travail ne
s'applique pas pour vous enfin voilà
néanmoins c'est quand même quelque chose
enfin qui a été une très très belle
avancée c'était un vrai progrès donc
aujourd'hui on continue à
on continue à informer les personnes sur
sur ces questions du droit du travail
notamment parce que les employeurs il y
a encore aujourd'hui des employeurs qui
contestent le code du travail donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très
compliqué pour pour les gens qui vit ça
parce que le droit est là mais
finalement en pratique les gens ne
peuvent pas l'utiliser alors nous les
constats qu'on fait sur le terrain sur
ce sujet là et les problématiques qu'on
en tire c'est que il y a vraiment un des
enjeux très complexes entre ces deux
sphères qui sont complètement
interconnectés c'est-à-dire le travail
et l'AMP mais qui ont finalement des
valeurs différentes donc le travail
c'est efficacité performance rendement
et puis quand on est en parcours d'AMP
et bien on est on est dans des valeurs
plus de fragilistes fragilité d'échecs
d'incertitude et tout ça crée des
conflits et des tensions qui sont qui
sont gérés par les individus concernés
puisque on est sur la responsabilité
individuelle et ça ça fait vraiment
beaucoup de dégâts encore aujourd'hui
sur les personnes qui sont concernées
donc de notre point de vue
il y a vraiment quelque chose
à travailler de façon plus globale sur
les représentations sociales que le
sujet de la fertilité de l'infertilité
et de l'AMP ont en France c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui en 2023 on a encore une
vision qui est globalement déformée de
la réalité de ce que ça implique la
fertilité l'infertilité et l'AMP et donc
comme c'est déformé on est encore sur
des préjugés des idées reçues qui font
que il n'y a pas de considération de
cette étape de vie qui est essayé
d'avoir des enfants et mais dans un
contexte de difficulté lié à
l'infertilité et on peut le voir dans
toutes les strates de la société par
exemple dans les politiques publiques et
bien le sujet infertilité est assez
absent là récemment il y a eu un travail
important qui a été fait sur les 1000
premiers jours et les 1000 premiers
jours mais il n'y a pas les questions de
fertilité d'infertilité ne sont pas
incluses dans ce projet là qui est un
projet très intéressant sur les
stratégies nationales santé sexuelle le
sujet infertilité est un peu abordé mais
plus sous l'angle il faut pas se droguer
il faut pas boire il faut pas fumer mais
pas sur les aspects plutôt psychosociaux
et de transformation de la société que
ça implique
mais bon ça c'est il y a quand même eu
des évolutions parce que moi en disant
j'ai bien vu comment les choses ont un
peu bougé sur sur ces choses-là mais on
a encore beaucoup de marge
d'amélioration donc comme l'a dit
Nathalie Massin avant moi c'est vrai que
l'infertilité c'est quelque chose qui
impacte de façon globale totale la vie
des gens qui sont touchés par ça ça
touche toutes les sphères de votre vie
que ça soit votre sexualité
votre l'estime de vous-même les
relations à votre famille les relations
à vos à vos amis les relations à la
société donc au niveau du travail
et c'est vraiment très difficile à vivre
parce qu'en plus ça se vit dans le
secret donc les gens s'isolent ne sont
honte et donc il y a vraiment
cet aspect très envahissant qui le sujet
est très massif et en même temps on ne
peut pas l'aborder parce que si on
l'aborde publiquement soit on a des
retours négatifs ou des on nous dit des
choses
encore aujourd'hui par exemple mais tu
as qu'à arrêter d'y penser ou alors tu
sais il y a plein d'enfants à adopter
dans le monde enfin voilà les idées
reçues persistent et ça c'est vraiment
très difficile il y a quelque chose qui
qui moi je trouve est vraiment très
marquant c'est qu'on est on est encore
quand même en 2023 en difficulté quand
on a une femme et qu'on annonce qu'on
est enceinte au sein d'une entreprise
c'est encore voilà c'est encore un
problème une femme enceinte dans une
entreprise c'est un problème elle peut
subir des remarques des pressions
éventuellement être mis au placard enfin
voilà il y a du harcèlement moral qui
peut être faite ça c'est encore la
réalité pour beaucoup de femmes en
France donc imaginez dans le cas de des
représentations négatives que je viens
d'évoquer sur l'infertilité quelqu'un
qui doit expliquer dans son entreprise
qu'elle voudrait être enceinte mais
qu'elle est en parcours d'ANP donc là on
est encore plus fragilisé parce qu'on
n'a pas cette légitimité historique de
la femme enceinte on est quelqu'un en
échec qui essaye d'avoir des enfants et
qui va être qui va s'absenter donc il y
a vraiment un poids énorme de cette
représentation très négative donc nous
on a fait plusieurs enquêtes où on a
participé à plusieurs enquêtes une en
2018 notamment qui s'intéressait au vécu
à la perception du parcours d'AMP pour
les personnes qui étaient en cours d'AMP
donc les il y avait 63 % des personnes
qui avaient expliqué qu'il y avait un
que le parcours d'un MP avait un impact
sur leur temps de travail très important
59% qui se disaient stressés dans le
cadre de leur travail et 54% des
personnes qui avaient répondu qui
disaient qu'elles avaient retardé ou
renoncer à changer de travail ou à
demander une augmentation
en 2020 au sein de l'association on
avait fait une enquête auprès de plus de
1500 personnes qui s'appelaient le
projet parental à l'épreuve du parcours
médical et là aussi ce qui ressortait
c'était le fort impact des parcours
d'AMP sur les aspects physiques
psychiques et symboliques de de par
rapport à au corps de la femme et par
rapport à toutes les questions
psychosociales que ça engendre
tout récemment donc en octobre 2022 on a
fait une un petit sondage rapide avec
Ipsos là qui était vraiment adressé que
aux femmes qui étaient en parcours d'AMP
et ce qui est ce qui est ressorti de ce
parcours de ce sondage pardon c'est que
84 % des femmes interrogées
expliquait que les parcours d'AMP ont un
impact sur leur vie professionnelle donc
84% c'est quand même beaucoup
81% des femmes disaient qu'ils avaient
un fort impact sur leur vie de couple et
94% des femmes qui avaient répondu
disait que le parcours était stressant
voilà après avec toutes les nuances de
stress en fonction de notre personnalité
de notre emploi de notre statut social
mais en tous les cas l'impact de
l'infertilité et de l'AMP est vraiment
massif sur sur la vie des personnes
concernées donc aujourd'hui comme je
l'ai un petit peu dit tout à l'heure le
droit il est là c'est à dire que
l'article 12-2516 et suivant du code du
travail c'est là c'est expliqué partout
dans tous les documents RH et tout ça
mais aujourd'hui il y a encore des
employeurs qui refusent qui mettent la
pression alors à leurs employés avec des
phrases que par exemple nous n'avons pas
à gérer vos problèmes de procréation
vous n'avez qu'à démissionné si vous
voulez avoir du temps non le droit du
travail ne s'applique pas pour vous non
les autorisations d'absence non non
c'est pas c'est pas pour vous enfin
voilà il y a et donc nous on les gens
qui nous sollicitent évidemment ce sont
les gens qui sont en difficulté avec ça
et ce qui est très impressionnant c'est
qu'on a beau les rassurer leur dire
voilà le droit dit ça la loi dit ça le
code du travail dit ça la réalité c'est
ça finalement également les gens
continuent à douter parce que le système
travail est un système très puissant et
dont on est très dépendant et donc les
gens se trouvent vraiment en fragilité
et en plus il y a il y a les très
grosses entreprises mais il y a aussi
les toutes petites entreprises et ça
peut être très compliqué quand vous êtes
le seul salarié face à votre patron il y
a vraiment quelque chose de la
protection que les gens n'ont pas moi je
souvent je dis aux gens de voir s'il y a
pas des délégués du personnel qui
peuvent les soutenir être un peu tiers
dans la relation ou alors les syndicats
et finalement on sait bien aussi comment
les la difficulté d'être en lien avec un
syndicat persiste les gens les gens
concernés se trouvent facilement très
seul dans cette histoire là et très
démunie
alors pour les tout à l'heure Nathalie
Massin disait que le il y a encore des
femmes ou des couples qui n'utilisent
pas ce droit là et ça c'est réel c'est à
dire qu'il y a des gens qui ont vraiment
peur de la stigmatisation que ça va ça
va ça va faire porter sur eux dans le
cas du travail alors moi je voulais je
rappelle enfin nous on a un document
qu'on a un dossier qui explique tout ça
là dans tous les détails pour les nos
adhérents et on rappelle qu'il y a quand
même l'article 9 du code civil qui
protège la vie privée et la santé est
dans la vie privée et l'article 226-1 du
code pénal qui protège tout ça
finalement voilà la loi est là sur ces
aspects de protection de de la
préservation de la vie privée mais
finalement c'est pas respecté parce
qu'on peut aller annoncer à son DRH
qu'on va être dans un parcours d'AMP et
une semaine après elle entendent partout
et voilà donc il y a quelque chose qui
qui maintient un état de peur qui permet
pas aux personnes d'utiliser le droit de
façon sereine
il y a un autre aspect sur ce il y a un
autre aspect que les personnes mettent
en place c'est des stratégies que les
femmes utilisent par rapport à leur
emploi à leur santé mentale
et qui s'impose pour beaucoup d'entre
elles encore aujourd'hui par rapport à
un choix qu'elle doit faire donc soit un
choix par défaut de réduire son temps de
travail pour avoir du temps pour pouvoir
faire les parcours d'AMP mais réduire
son temps de travail ça veut dire qu'on
perd de l'argent il y a des femmes qui
décident de faire de l'intérim pour
avoir une espèce de liberté mais c'est
pareil l'intérim ça fragilise quand même
il y a des femmes qui décident de
quitter leur travail pour arrêter de
subir la pression parce que la pression
elle a subi déjà par rapport au parcours
d'AMP et la pression qui se rajoute par
rapport au parcours professionnel donc
il y a des gens qui décident de quitter
leur travail mais c'est effectivement
une perte de ressources et une perte
d'épanouissement personnel par rapport à
son activité professionnelle et puis il
y a aussi des choix qui sont imposés par
le contexte professionnel c'est-à-dire
des personnes qui sont mis au placard à
qui on ne fait pas on ne propose pas
d'augmentation on ne propose pas de
changement de poste des personnes qui
sont licenciées mais on peut pas prouver
que le licenciement était lié au
parcours d'ANP parce qu'on trouve tout
enfin les employeurs trouvent toujours
des motifs des personnes qui se
retrouvent au chômage et qui des
personnes qui qui ont pour qui la
situation impacte vraiment l'estime de
soi et la développement personnel on va
dire les revenus et les projets
personnels alors un autre aspect parce
que quand je disais tout à l'heure que
les choses s'articulent entre la MP et
le travail c'est qu'il y a quelque chose
sur la question de la prise en charge
médicale de l'infertilité et de la
fertilité en France et nous on aimerait
beaucoup que il faut enfin il faut
éviter que les gens rentrent en parcours
d'AMP donc pour éviter que les gens
rentrent en parcours d'AMP il y a
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
renforcer c'est l'information la
prévention sur la santé reproductive et
sur tout ce qui impacte la reproduction
et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
un autre aspect sur ces sur ces parcours
médicaux c'est de les rendre plus
efficace parce que comme disait Nathalie
Massin et bien il y a plein de
rendez-vous ça dure longtemps et ça
s'organise des fois pas très simplement
donc il faut vraiment il y a une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur comment rendre
plus efficace les parcours d'AMP dans le
temps mais aussi en termes de
d'obtention d'une grossesse de temps
pour obtenir une grossesse et pour ça il
y a la question de l'amélioration des
techniques il y a la question de l'accès
aux soins et aussi l'accès aux soins sur
le territoire
alors je rentre pas dans les détails
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup de temps
mais sur l'accès aux soins par rapport
au territoire il y a la question du
trajet parce que voilà il y a 101 centre
d'AMP en France et ils sont répartis sur
le territoire et il y a des zones où
l'accès est difficile à et notamment
entre le lieu du travail le Léo Messie
et le centre d'AMP
et cette question elle se elle est
encore plus renforcée dans les zones
rurales donc il y a des beaucoup de gens
qui vivent à plus de deux heures d'un
centre d'AMP et donc là là où les
autorisations d'absence étaient prévues
pour quelques heures pour permettre de
faire ces rendez-vous et puis après
d'aller au travail finalement il y a des
gens qui qui ont besoin d'une journée
entière voire de plusieurs jours et ça
c'est aussi un motif de conflit avec les
employeurs un motif de conflit
pour la personne elle-même parce qu'elle
se sent en défaut
surtout parce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure le cette question du temps de
transport reste floue alors ça permet ce
flou permet aux grosses entreprises
d'avoir d'être très généreuses c'est à
dire qu'il y a des grosses entreprises
qui ont dit à leur salarié ben voilà oui
on vous autorise une demi-journée voire
une journée d'absence et c'est très
généreux et c'est très appréciable sauf
que il y a plein de gens qui ne
travaillent pas dans les grosses
entreprises et qui sont vraiment en
défaut par rapport à ça tu ajoutes à ça
la question des déserts médicaux parce
que il y a il y a vraiment l'accès aux
soins dans les déserts médicaux qui est
compliqué
et puis aussi il y a la question des
personnes qui vivent dans les dromes et
les comes qui pour certains n'ont pas de
centre d'AMP alors il y a un centre
d'AMP en Nouvelle-Calédonie il y en a un
Guadeloupe mais il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres territoires où il n'y a pas de
Sanda MP ou lorsqu'il y a un centre
d'AMP le centre d'AMP ne fait pas toutes
les techniques et donc ça oblige les
personnes à faire de très longs voyages
jusqu'en métropole et donc là je vous
laisse imaginer les questions de que ça
engendre en termes de rupture
professionnelle de ces jours en
métropole qu'il faut adapte qu'il faut
trouver la perte de repère l'isolement
pour des gens qui sont déjà fragilisés
par le les parcours d'AMP donc voilà ça
c'est le tableau un peu général de la
situation et donc dans les propositions
que
on voudrait faire et bien évidemment ça
rejoint ce qui a déjà été dit et ce qui
a été dit aussi dans d'autres
présentations dans d'autres tables
rondes que vous avez proposé
il y a vraiment vraiment une nécessité
que la société et le monde du travail
repense la question de la considération
qu'on adresse aux femmes qu'on adresse à
leur santé et donc à l'articulation de
la vie privée et de la vie
professionnelle parce que tant que que
la société est donc la société c'est les
entreprises les individus n'ont pas
décidé tous ensemble de de changer la
manière d'être et la manière de faire on
va rester dans des dans des choses comme
ça un peu compliquées
évidemment il ne faut pas oublier les
hommes parce que la grande majorité des
parcours se font dans des dans encore
dans des
couples hétérosexuels et les hommes
aussi sont infertiles et comme ça a été
déjà dit la charge mentale est encore
beaucoup portée par les femmes mais de
plus en plus d'hommes s'investissent
prennent en charge les rendez-vous
prennent en charge les piqûres donc il y
a vraiment quelque chose à articuler
entre les hommes et les femmes
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
pense que le sujet le plus important
c'est que fertilité et infertilité
deviennent vraiment des sujets de santé
publique et ça donc dans la dans le
cadre de la loi 2021 la loi de éthique
on a obtenu un plan fertilité ensuite en
2022 février 2022 il y a le rapport sur
les causes d'infertilité qui a été mis à
Olivier remis à Olivier Olivier Véran et
depuis c'est un peu en stand by c'est à
dire que dans ce rapport il y a plein de
recommandations alors certes elles ne
sont pas il n'y a pas de sujets sur
justement le travail comme ça a été fait
pour la stratégie nationale endométriose
mais ce rapport sur les causes
d'infertilité devait déboucher sur une
stratégie nationale fertilité
infertilité dans laquelle on aurait pu
travailler ces questions du travail mais
bon pour l'instant les choses sont en
stand-by
donc là je vais peut-être pas rentrer
dans tous les détails parce que voilà il
y a j'ai pas trop le temps mais il y a
la question d'améliorer les améliorer
les taux de réussite les
téléconsultations enfin des choses qui
ont déjà été dites donc au niveau de
l'État je pense vraiment qu'il y a une
nécessité
urgente que les politiques publiques
influent insuffle vraiment ce changement
réel sur les questions de la santé des
femmes et de l'articulation avec le
travail et aussi donc avec l'assistance
médicale à la procréation mais s'il n'y
a pas une vraie politique publique qui
dit bon maintenant on arrête et on va
faire autrement et on va considérer tout
ça autrement on va toutes les petits
tous les petits défauts qu'on a énoncé
les unes et les autres vont perdurer
dans le temps et on sait très bien que
les choses sont que les changements sont
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre donc c'est
pour ça que nous on appelle vraiment à
quelque chose de d'important de positif
parce que si on améliore tout ça et ben
on va tous gagner en amélioration de de
la qualité de vie de la qualité de vie
au travail et ça sera bénéfique pour
tout le monde
donc il y a la question de faire
respecter les droits d'en créer de
nouveaux de faire respecter la question
du droit du travail et de mettre en
oeuvre au sein des entreprises des une
vraie une vraie sécurité de la
confidentialité des informations qui
sont qui sont diffusées par les
personnes la nécessité la nécessité de
mettre en oeuvre des grandes campagnes
de communication publique sur ces sujets
donc santé des femmes sans assistance
médicale à la procréation une nécessité
de mobiliser les partenaires sociaux
donc à la fois les entreprises et les
syndicats pour que tous ensemble on
réfléchisse à ces situations là et qu'on
avance dans le même sens
et enfin une nécessité de soutenir les
associations qui font un important
travail sur le terrain auprès des
personnes en ce qui concerne les
entreprises pour nous il y a une vraie
urgence de faire de la formation et des
informations au sein des entreprises sur
la fertilité l'infertilité l'assistance
médicale à la procréation pour que les
les RH les patrons les salariés prennent
conscience de la situation et donc
deviennent plus accueillants plus
bienveillant et il y a cette attention
spéciale sur les petits et les moyens
des entreprises je sais voilà il faut
vraiment trouver quelque chose je pense
qu'il faut s'appuyer sur ce qui existe
déjà c'est à dire qu'il y a il y a tout
un tas d'entreprises qui sont qui
commencent à rentrer dans un cercle
vertueux et qui sont pour qu'il faudrait
mettre en avant et qui pourrait être des
modèles donc il y a l'observatoire des
temps
d'étendre la qualité de vie au travail
qui qui fait signer la charte de la
parentalité en entreprise et donc il y a
des entreprises qui s'engagent sur les
aspects désirs d'enfants montrons
l'exemple et montrons que ça existe et
que c'est possible il y a le parental
challenge aussi qui est en train de
faire signer tout un tas de
d'entreprises sur ces engagement sur ses
aspects de considération d'endométriose
du sepk de l'infertilité et ça c'est ça
existe déjà appuyons-nous sur ces
exemples vertueux
et puis la question de la médecine parce
que il y a deux autres intervenantes
après voilà
il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites je pense aussi et qui sont un
petit peu communes donc je vous remercie
et puis je vais peut-être passer la
parole aux deux autres intervenants tu
auras des questions éventuellement des
rapporteurs mais sinon on risque de
finir la Réunion vous vous et moi
présidente puisque je suis obligée de
rester et parce qu'il y a d'autres
réunions derrière donc je suis obligé de
vous couper madame donc je vais tout de
suite passer la parole à Brigitte le
tombe donc qui est gynécologue et membre
du bureau du groupe d'études sur la
ménopause et le vieillissement hormonal
je vous remercie madame merci madame la
Présidente merci mesdames les
signatrices de m'avoir invité juste une
toute petite rectification je ne suis
plus hospitalière après 40 ans
d'activités hospitalières j'ai quitté
mon poste et je suis désormais en
libéral en cumulant retraite j'allais
dire mais à quel âge avez-vous pris
votre retraite
je vous laisse je vais vous parler d'une
étape qui est tout à fait physiologique
on a parlé de ce qui était pathologique
je vais vous parler d'une étape simple
si la vie d'une étape de la vie génitale
des femmes c'est la dernière c'est la
ménopause alors je suis ménopausée et
j'ose le dire comme 100% des femmes de
plus de 55 ans 50% de la population
française
sans doute et Jules la chance moi quant
à moi de ne pas m'angoisser et de ne pas
en souffrir parce que je suis
gynécologue je n'ai pas eu à craindre un
vieillissement intellectuel prématuré ou
une entrée en dépression ne me
reconnaissant plus sans oser et on
parlait comme certaines femmes
d'aujourd'hui qui éventuellement ne font
pas le lien de ses déficients tout à
fait transitoire avec une carence
hormonale et que surtout l'on somme de
toujours rester jeune et performante on
parle aujourd'hui plus facilement
d'endométriose de règles d'infertilité
mais le dernier des tabou celui qu'il
reste bien le dernier d'État bout
féminin c'est la ménopause il faut bien
avouer que cette ménopause tout à fait
physiologique qui survient vers 51 ans
s'avère être une véritable inégalité
homme-femme majeur
car elle correspond non seulement un
arrêt de la fertilité ce qui bien sûr
peut s'avérer très douloureux pour les
femmes qui n'ont pas leurs comptes
d'enfants mais aussi à la différence
également des hommes qui eux continuent
à avoir une sécrétion hormonale et des
sécrétion de spermatozoïdes un arrêt
total de la sécrétion des hormones
féminines par les ovaires que sont le
stradiol et la progestérone
au 21e siècle et en tout cas en France
on ne parle pas de sa ménopause comme si
c'était honteux pour une femme d'avoir
plus de 50 ans
mélange-t-on encore fertilité avec
féminité il est vrai que la giseme
touche essentiellement les femmes un
homme qui commence à accuser quelques
rides et des temps de crise s'avère
plutôt séduisant avoir un peu de charme
une femme au contraire c'est une vieille
peau avec des vapeurs
la ménopause est étonnamment encore un
sujet tabou alors qu'une femme a une
espérance de vie de 85 ans c'est-à-dire
un tiers de sa vie qu'elle va vivre en
période ménopause
quand avez-vous entendu pour la dernière
fois prononcer le mot ménopause autour
de vous par votre mère votre femme votre
sœur peut-être mais en tout cas pas par
une collègue qui craint au contraire si
elle évoque sa ménopause se fait
d'avouer non seulement son âge mais
aussi son éventuel fragilité
pour sortir de cette situation si
délétère pour les femmes au travail
comme sur le plan personnel familial
conjugal et social il faut absolument
informer les femmes mais aussi les
hommes et qu'en fin on ose tous
prononcer ce mot de ménopause alors je
me suis fait aider par un diaporama
que je ne peux pas vous poser parce
qu'il passe pas visiblement
et vous l'avez pas sur l'écran
alors je vais me mettre là je vais me
mettre là pour le regarder
donc je vais me mettre là
[Musique]
oui je disais informé pour dédramatiser
et préparer les femmes il faut nommer
pour lutter contre les moqueries les
lieux communs et on a pas cessé d'en
parler la stigmatisation il faut
préparer les femmes leur environnement
et les employeurs à cette transition
physiologique qui angoisse et qui
survient souvent chez les femmes alors
qu'elles sont au sommet de leur carrière
il faut positiver pour lutter contre
cette culture du secret à la base des
attitudes sexistes et de la Gys et de la
giseme qui touche davantage les femmes
au travail cela d'autant que se sentant
moins performante manquante confiance en
elle à cet âge certaines femmes
angoissées refusent les promotions et se
tournent vers une retraite prématurée ou
une reconversion
alors mesdames les présidents vous nous
avez rappelé tous les symptômes du
climatère que vous connaissiez bien donc
les bouffées de chaleur et autres mais
il faut savoir que ces bouffées de
chaleur et toute cette symptomatologie
va avoir des répercussions sur la
qualité de vie globale avec vous voyez
des troubles de concentration des
troubles de la mémorisation qui arrive
déjà dès la périménopause avant même la
redéfinitif des règles et qui angoissent
les femmes qui pensent que ça y est
c'est le vieillissement puisqu'elles
sont pas le lien après il y a les
troubles du sommeil on en a parlé les
troubles du sommeil ça a des
répercussions majeures sur la qualité de
vie et sur bien sûr la compétitivité au
travail et puis ça des répercussions sur
le poids c'est des répercussions sur
l'humeur le stress la dépression
l'irritabilité donc tes répercussions
sur la vie personnelle bien sûr la vie
familiale conjugale et
aujourd'hui la vie professionnelle
alors les symptômes liés à la
périménopause et la ménopause vous avez
ici une étude que l'on a faite avec le
Gemi en 2013 qui vous montre combien ces
symptômes sont nombreux et le
pourcentage des femmes touchées regardez
sur la première ligne au moins un
symptôme de ménopause pour les femmes de
45 à 50 ans c'est 94% des femmes et pour
les femmes de 61 60 à 65 ans c'est
encore 73% des femmes qui signale avoir
un des symptômes qui sont listés là donc
les plus fréquents bouffées de chaleur
sur nocturne prise de poids troubles du
sommeil changement de l'humeur et puis
maux de tête migraine troubles de la
mémoire et aussi les troubles urinaires
alors on sait qu'il y a
une symptomatologie climatérique qui
n'est plus prise en charge et on a comme
on avait fait cette étude en 2013 on a
fait une nouvelle étude en 2020 sur 5000
femmes pour connaître justement si ces
symptômes étaient pris en charge et vous
allez voir cette publication donc c'est
une étude française qui a été publiée
dans Le maturité à ce qui est le journal
de la Société européenne de ménopause et
qui a été publiée en 2022 et voyez les
symptômes fonctionnels et syndromes
génitaux urinaires de la ménopause ça
touche 87% des femmes pour ce qui est la
symptomatologie générale et 67% des
femmes pour ce qui concerne le syndrome
génito urinaire de la ménopause on
appelle le syndrome génito-urinaire
parce que vous savez que si l'on parle
simplement de sécheresse vaginale de
difficultés sexuelles c'est assez
stigmatisant c'est difficile d'en parler
et on oublie qu'associer à cette
symptomatologie il y a aussi une
symptomatologie urinaire qui peut bien
sûr avoir des répercussions dans la
qualité de vie au travail
alors regardez sur ces 5000 femmes qui
ont été étudiées entre 50 et 65 ans il
n'y a que 6% des femmes qui sont
traitées pour une symptomatologie par un
traitement hormonal de ménopause je
voudrais vous rappeler quand même
qu'avant la WHI cette étude américaine
qui a été publiée en 2002 et qui a
vraiment déstabilisé complètement les
professionnels et les femmes par une
balance bénéficerie qui était venue
négative vis-à-vis du traitement
hormonal on traitait en France environ
35% des femmes aujourd'hui on entrait
plus que 6%. alors que la
symptomatologie majeure dont je vous ai
montré les différents symptômes vont
toucher de façon grave 25% des femmes en
péril et postes ménopause immédiate ce
qui signifie qu'il y a au moins une
femme sur quatre qui devrait avoir accès
à une thérapeutique franchement
efficace 3 sur 4 vont avoir des
symptômes et une sur quatre peut-être
pas vraiment elle va vivre ça ménopause
comme vraiment libératrice on en a parlé
tout à l'heure justement libératrice des
règles libératrice de la nécessité
contraceptive mais pour trois femmes sur
quatre il y a une symptomatologie une
femme sur quatre une symptomatologie qui
peut être vraiment majeur
regardez la persistance des bouffées
vasomotrices c'est la symptômes
symptômes le plus connu alors pour
beaucoup on pense que les bouffées
vasomotrices ça va durer un an ou deux
on entend régulièrement des femmes moi
dans ma consultation j'entends
régulièrement des femmes qui me disent
j'en ai parlé à mon médecin il m'a dit
que ça allait passer que c'était pas si
grave d'ici un nom de ça va passer non
non la moyenne vous voyez cette étude
c'est une étude multiethnique qui a
débarré en 97 qui suit les femmes donc
depuis très longtemps la moyenne du
temps des bouffées de chaleur c'est sept
ans et demi et pour certaines femmes ça
peut être beaucoup plus longtemps il y a
des femmes qui 15 ans après 20 ans après
encore une symptomatologie vasomotrice
alors on connaît les troubles du
climatère qui vont gêner les femmes
essentiellement en début de ménopause en
périménopause la symptomatologie
génitaux urinaire donc avec les
difficultés
urinaires la peau la quiurie les cystite
théories nucléaires et petits problèmes
de continence parfois ça peut toucher
les femmes assez tôt et puis plus
tardivement si on n'a pas pris en charge
cette carence oestrogénique pour
certaines femmes à risque bien sûr il y
aura un risque d'ostéoporose avec des
fractures graves un risque
d'athérosclérose avec des accidents
cardiovasculaires éventuellement on a
alors pas de certitude mais
vraisemblablement un certain lien entre
cette que ce strogénique et les troubles
cognitifs les problèmes de démarche
ultérieure
ça touche quand même énormément de
femmes
femmes vous voyez 14 millions
aujourd'hui il y a 500000 femmes qui
entre en ménopause par an donc c'est
vraiment pas quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas prendre en considération d'autant
que ça touche 100% des femmes alors on a
la Société nationale de ménopause qui
est le gène vie le groupe d'études de la
ménopause et du vieillissement hormonal
on a un site professionnel avec une
partie grand public et on a donc sur la
page d'accueil de ce site donc les
informations sur la balance bénéficerie
du traitement hormonal et puis
l'information sur l'insuffisance
ovarienne prématurée qui je vous
rappelle est une ménopause qui survient
bien trop tôt bien avant 40 ans et qui
nécessite absolument un traitement
hormonal que l'on appelle cette fois
substitutif pour que cette femme n'est
pas ses risques notamment
cardiovasculaires et ostéoporique bien
plus tôt que pour les femmes qui ont une
carence hormonale à la cinquantaine
alors on a beaucoup travaillé pour
essayer de rappeler l'intérêt du
traitement hormonald de ménopause au
niveau des professionnels et donc en
2021 ont été publiés les recommandations
pour la pratique clinique par le CNJF et
le GMV
ensuite on a essayé de développer
l'information auprès des femmes parce
que ce qui est important c'est non
seulement d'informer les praticiens et
comment ils peuvent accompagner voire
traiter les patientes mais il faut aussi
informer les femmes sur cette
symptomatologie qui peut être
particulièrement variée et leur
permettre d'en parler on a essayé de
déployer des ménopauses café comme c'est
une expérience qui a été débutée en
Belgique on a commencé en 2019 il faut
bien avouer que ce speed dating
ménopause ou en fait on avait des tables
rondes avec un spécialiste et une
dizaine de femmes pour parler et des
problèmes psychologiques et des
problèmes de poids et des problèmes
cardiovasculaires et des problèmes de
ostéo-articulaires ça demande un
investissement important la présence de
professionnels et donc c'est quelque
chose qui est assez coûteux
on s'est tourné vers les applications
puisque aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
informer sans les réseaux sociaux et on
travaille sur le contenu d'information
médicale de l'application qui est
l'application
omena
ensuite on a fait deux conférences de
presse une conférence de presse le 18
octobre 2022 18 octobre c'est la journée
de ménopause internationale je suis sûr
que vous ne le saviez pas ça fait très
longtemps la société internationale de
ménopause a une journée internationale
le 18 octobre qui n'est pas vraiment
entre guillemets utilisés en France est
utilisé par ailleurs et dans et chaque
année il y a un thème spécifique qui est
traité donc le 18 octobre 2022 c'était
le fog le brouillard cérébral parce que
ce brouillard cérébral ces troubles de
concentration et de mémorisation qui
arrivent en périménopause et en début de
ménopause il faut emmener de comprendre
pourquoi comment en tout cas sachez bien
que ce Fogg est quelque chose de tout à
fait transitoire donc pas de souci sur
les capacités intellectuelles
c'est pour ça
nous avons été aidés par le laboratoire
Vichy qui a qui nous a permis de
d'écrire cette tribune d'engagement pour
une meilleure prise en charge de la
ménopause et du libération de la parole
avec un QR code en assistant sur la
formation des professionnels concernés
au-delà de leur domaine d'expertise pour
nous il est important que tout
professionnel de santé quel qu'il soit
médecin généraliste dermatologues bien
sûr gynécologue cardiologue puisse
parler à une femme de son éventuel
symptomatologie ménopausées il faut
pouvoir créer des
conditions de dialogue serein à l'issue
de chaque consultation pour que chaque
femme de plus de 45 ans sache à peu près
ce qu'elle peut ressentir et comment
éventuellement elle peut le gérer donc
pouvoir
identifier toute cette symptomatologie
pouvoir faire appel et puis tout
récemment encore en février on a eu une
conférence de presse de hall for
ménopause où là c'est un collectif qui
regroupe à la fois des professionnels de
santé et des femmes de la société pour
justement interpeller sur la nécessité
d'information sur le fait qu'il faut
toucher tous les professionnels de santé
qui devraient pouvoir parler de
ménopause à chaque femme dans cette
tranche d'âge créer éventuellement un
diplôme universitaire de patients
experts dédié à la ménopause créer un
parcours de santé pour les femmes des 45
ans et puis vous voyez le cinquième
point interpeller les dirigeants
d'entreprises de grands groupes sur le
sujet de la ménopause et enfin si
possible
identifier et rendre visible une
représentante de la santé des femmes au
gouvernement
alors il y a déjà eu un travail qui a
été publié
par maturitas donc le journal de la
Société européenne de ménopause sur les
recommandations de la prise en charge de
la ménopause et de ce que l'on pourrait
faire au niveau du milieu du travail je
vous
présente quelques lignes donc il y a des
répercussions bien sûr des modalités de
travail sur les symptômes de la
ménopause par exemple dans les symptômes
il y a des douleurs articulaires il y a
des femmes qui ont vraiment des douleurs
articulaires marquées du fait de la
carence œstrogénique dans les travaux
physiques ça peut être un problème et
puis il y a aussi la ménopause qui peut
altérer le travail par exemple pour les
femmes qui ont des travaux
essentiellement intellectuels le fait
qu'il fatigue des troubles de
concentration et de mémorisation ça peut
bien sûr avoir des répercussions
la fatigue la perte de mémoire les
difficultés et de concentration les
pertes de confiance en soi peuvent
altérer la performance des travaux
intellectuels il faut qu'on et ça peut
conduire bien sûr certaines femmes à une
perte d'estime d'elle-même et parfois un
syndrome dépressif les femmes ont
souvent peur de la stigmatiser et de ce
silence or les employeurs non seulement
doivent assurer la santé et la sécurité
au travail mais ils n'ont aucun intérêt
à perdre les compétences et les talents
précieux pour une symptomatologie
souvent transitoire qui se doit de
pouvoir être dite comprise accompagnée
voire traiter donc il est important
d'avoir cet écoute cette adaptation et
cette flexibilité dont on a déjà parlé
les employeurs doivent favoriser la
culture ouverte inclusive et solidaire
de l'expression des symptômes de
ménopause dont tous les lieux et modèles
professionnels avec une approche
positive
et surtout un zéro tolérance pour
l'intimidation le rabaissement le
harcèlement tout en sachant que
certaines femmes ne désireront peut-être
pas en parler il faut veiller à ce que
les femmes puissent avoir accès à un
professionnel de santé formé à cette
problématique permettre la flexibilité
des codes vestimentaires des uniformes
en utilisant des tissus thermiquement
confortables voire bien sûr la
flexibilité horaire prévoir un contrôle
de la température et une ventilation
adaptée sur le lieu de travail
prévoir un accès à l'eau fraîche bien
sûr et surtout un accès des vestiaires
et des sanitaires privatifs comme on a
parlé il peut y avoir des difficultés de
urinaires qui nécessitent de pouvoir
avoir un accès à des sanitaires sans
problème avoir pour les pour les femmes
qui ont des rôles accès sur le client ou
orienté vers le public il faut permettre
des pauses pour gérer des symptômes
vasomoteurs particulièrement intenses
pouvoir se retirer sans avoir à trouver
toujours un prétexte
tout professionnel de santé devrait
avoir eu une formation requise sur les
ménopause et savoir que ces symptômes
climatiques peuvent affecter le
bien-être et les capacités au travail
avec en conséquence parfois la nécessité
d'une adaptation transitoire pour éviter
la mise en arrêt de travail le chômage
voire pire le désir de tous ces c'est
bien avant la retraite avant de se fait
avec de ce fait un risque de perte de
revenus de pension et bien sûr de
bien-être ultérieure notre devoir c'est
de donner les clés ne pas banaliser mais
permettre d'orienter d'accompagner et
d'adresser pour un éventuel traitement
donc en entreprise ce qui me semble
important c'est d'informer les cadres
les employeurs et les employés mais je
crois que ça passe surtout et c'est pour
ça que tout notre travail jusque là a
été essentiellement tourné vers la
société vers
une information large de tous les
publics que ce soit les femmes bien sûr
mais les hommes également
et puis je vous rappelle mais vous en
avez fait mention tout à l'heure qu'il y
a eu donc un rapport parlementaire qui a
été publié en octobre 2022 en Angleterre
avec pas mal de propositions des gens en
Angleterre ils donnent la possibilité
d'éviter des frais de prescription pour
le traitement hormonal et puis ils ont
donné par exemple la possibilité aux
femmes d'avoir accès à des œstrogènes
locaux directement en pharmacie sans
prescription
voilà je vous remercie de votre écoute
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup madame
pour cette présentation
concise et efficace
avec ce document à l'appui je vais
dernier donner pardon la parole à notre
dernière intervenante Rachel
Saada pardon ça date qui est avocate au
bar de Paris merci merci de votre
invitation merci de me donner la parole
alors quand on parle en dernier on
bénéficié d'un avantage et d'un
inconvénient l'avantage c'est que
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites et
que je vais donc pour voir raccourcir
mon propos je l'espère ce qui me fait
une transition vers l'inconvénient c'est
à dire que nos capacités d'attention et
de concentration après presque deux
heures d'exposer sont un peu à moindris
alors je vais commencer par une boutade
en vous demandant
si la non mixité de cette et voulu ou
subit
en réalité la délégation en droit des
femmes compte des hommes et des femmes
et il se trouve que ce matin vous avez
une représentation extrêmement quand
même extrêmement féminine éducation
précieuse oui mais de l'intérêt c'est
soucis c'est souvent le cas et c'est
vrai que c'est sujet voilà concernent
hélas plus souvent les femmes or il
concerne les hommes et les femmes dans
la réalité des faits bon on vous laisse
continuer mais vous avez eu raison de
souligner c'était ma crainte nous ferons
état que ce soit
vous leur direz qu'ils ont été regrettés
très regretté et presque vilipendée
parce que
il le mériterait
je vais beaucoup vous déprimer nous ne
le pardonnerez vous avez tout à l'heure
manifester lors
d'un exposé mais enfin vous voulez nous
nous couper le moral alors oui je suis
spécialiste en droit du travail et en
droit de la sécurité sociale et mon
propos va correspondre à ce que je
constate depuis près de 40 ans
d'exercices professionnels
constat biaisé par un engagement qui est
le mien qui est celui de ne plaider
cocoter des salariés des élus du
personnel et
des syndicats
alors je vais rebondir
brièvement sur des points qui ont été
évoqués
je vais aller droit au but parce que
comme on l'a dit enfin comme je l'ai dit
il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont été
évoqué
et je vais faire des observations
d'abord sur la question des règles
douloureuses et comment on pourrait
prendre ça en compte et ensuite sur les
questions en effet d'aide médicale à la
à la procréation
pour conclure sur ce qui a déjà été dit
également c'est sur l'arsenal dont nous
disposons déjà
donc à mon sens ce n'est pas tellement
une question d'outils supplémentaire j'y
viendrai à la fin de mon propos c'est
une question à la fois de droit positif
c'est à dire comment les juridictions
s'emparent de ces outils
c'est une question d'accès au droit et
d'accès au juge et c'est une question de
rapport de domination en réalité
alors je passe sur le flex c'est un
problème numériquement très important
etc je passe sur le fait que il existe
déjà dans certains pays des congés
menstruels pour moi sa présente pas
beaucoup d'intérêt parce que chaque pays
a son histoire vous avez évoqué madame
la Présidente
une politique
britannique c'est à mon sens pas pas
très bon exemple parce que le droit du
travail
en Grande-Bretagne c'est pas ce qui se
fait de mieux et
tout est passé au crible de la
discrimination en réalité les Anglais
n'ont plus de droit du travail ils n'ont
plus qu'un droit de la discrimination
donc on va chacun dans son couloir
chercher des éléments de la
discrimination donc
votre projet il est intéressant mais il
pose beaucoup de questions
puisqu'il interroge la notion de maladie
et la notion de handicap est-ce que on
veut se diriger vers ça c'est à dire
est-ce que on veut évoquer c'est ça la
première chose c'est une réflexion
presque philosophique c'est voilà c'est
voilà c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
que je veux développer
mais il faut se poser cette question la
notion de maladie la notion de handicap
sachant qu'il faut pas non plus
mythifier la reconnaissance
de la qualité de travailleurs handicapé
d'accord le RQTH dont on a parlé ne
mytifions rien ça n'apporte que très peu
de protection supplémentaires c'est un
parcours du combattant les MDPH ne sont
pas tendres avec
les demandeurs
c'est un pataquès absolu et franchement
c'est c'est presque une souffrance
supplémentaire
sachant que je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut pas le faire mais
voilà là aussi je suis
réservé sur les effets de promouvoir la
reconnaissance de travailleurs
handicapés ça change je vous le rappelle
que les employeurs en réalité ne sont
intéressés que par une chose
c'est d'éviter de payer les amendes à la
Gifi c'est pas spécialement de recruter
des travailleurs handicapés parce qu'ils
sont bienveillants je n'aurais pas
beaucoup de goût à utiliser ce terme
parce que d'abord je
dois avoir mauvais esprit ou en tout cas
je suis contaminé par ma pratique
professionnelle qui fait que je ne vois
pas beaucoup de bienveillance dans les
entreprises et que c'est un terme qui me
paraît trop neutre et et qui n'interroge
pas le rapport de domination extrêmement
fort qui existe dans les entreprises
alors je viens quand même à une
proposition
concernant la question effectivement des
règles douloureuses et de ce que on a pu
appeler je déteste cette nomination
cette dénomination le congé menstruel
c'est la question des jours de carence
et moi je vous propose un biais
parce que bon j'ai été prévenu à cet
tardivement de mon de mon intervention
j'étais en congé et c'est mon syndicat
le Syndicat des Avocats de France qui me
dit mais il faut que tu y ailles
j'ai réfléchi pendant mes congés j'ai
réfléchi à alors je me suis dit bon le
problème évidemment ça peut pas être un
congé payé parce que si vous balancez au
patron que après la cinquième semaine de
congés payés qui est arrivé en 80 il va
y avoir cinq semaines supplémentaires
parce que ça fait ça c'est deux jours et
demi par mois les congés payés on va pas
leur annoncer qu'il va y avoir des
congés payés donc ça ne peut que passer
alors en Espagne c'est l'État qui
finance
les jours de carence en revanche je me
suis dit mais bon sang
c'est précisément par le prisme de la
discrimination indirecte
qu'on peut peut-être arriver
à supprimer les jours de carence parce
que si vous étudiez les rapports
concernant les arrêts maladie les femmes
sont
50% plus touchés par les arènes maladie
que les hommes en 2022
il y a j'ai consulté une une étude qui
précise que
le taux qui concerne les femmes
bon évidemment je leur trouve pas mais
oui voilà je les retrouvais c'est 6,8 en
2021 pardon
6,8% pour les femmes
4,6% pour les hommes ça fait pile 50% de
plus d'arrêt de travail pour les femmes
et donc peut-être que par ce biais de la
discrimination indirecte dont vous
connaissez sûrement la notion c'est à
dire qu'en réalité c'est une disposition
légale ou réglementaire qui n'avaient
absolument pas pour objet de discriminer
mais qui a pour effet de discriminer et
donc comme ces congés pourraient serait
court
évidemment que les femmes sont frappées
beaucoup plus par les trois jours de
carence donc faire sauter ce verrou des
trois jours de carence ça présente
plusieurs avantages
sa présence
l'avantage évidemment de permettre aux
femmes d'être plus facilement en arrêt
travail sans perte financière ça n'a pas
d'effet sur l'employeur puisque
l'employeur disons ça n'a pas d'effet
autre sur amplaire parce que l'employeur
vous le savez au bout d'un certain d'une
certaine ancienneté il est tenu de
compléter les
igss
au-delà
de trois ans d'ancienneté ou d'un an si
la convention collective le prévoit il
est tenu par une loi de mensualisation
qui est 78 qui a été codifiée maintenant
depuis quelques années
a grosso modo 90% du salaire mais c'est
pendant une durée limitée ce qui veut
dire que ce qu'il paierait au titre de
ces trois jours de carence qui aurait
disparu
ça part du contingent
qu'il doit régler ça ne s'ajoute pas
donc ça ne m'écoute pas plus cher donc
ça c'est peut-être une piste de
réflexion c'est une piste qui est
intéressante aussi parce qu'elle
préserve
absolument le secret médical et que moi
personnellement en qualité de juriste il
n'est pas envisageable de rompre le
secret médical et d'ouvrir une brèche de
cette nature et dans le cadre des
recherches vacancières que j'ai faites
et bien je constate que osez le
féminisme
refuse que ce que une brèche de cette
nature soit ouverte donc voilà la
proposition qui me paraîtrait
la plus je dirais facile à mettre en
oeuvre puisque pour le volet sécu il y
aura le motif et
pas pour l'employeur et trois jours les
trois jours de carence disparaîtraient
il est clair que
les femmes n'en abuseraient pas puisque
on voit très bien comment elle se
comporte que ce soit au Japon en
Indonésie en Australie ou ailleurs au
Japon où le congé existe depuis 1945
elles sont aujourd'hui
0,9%
à en profiter et dans d'autres pays
qu'ils ont également mis en place que ce
soit la Corée du Sud ou
l'Indonésie c'est peanuts donc ce qui
veut dire que il n'y aura pas d'abus et
d'une manière générale en matière de
droit il n'y a jamais d'abus il y a
plutôt des sous-déclarations
que des abus et ça on le sait très bien
alors maintenant je vous ai dit on peut
envisager ça je vais vous parler de
l'inconvénient de l'inconvénient
parce que vous avez tout à l'heure parlé
madame Rio
non madame leur bat des plans je vous
avais parlé du licenciement dont vous
aviez
recueilli la confidence en vous
indignant
et ben oui
l'employeur a absolument le droit de
licencier pendant un arrêt de travail il
a absolument le droit de licencier pour
une absence prolongée mais aussi ce que
les gens savent moins
pour des absences répétées
et la jurisprudence est assez féroce
c'est-à-dire que il faut qu'il justifie
d'une désorganisation et du nécessité de
remplacement mais s'il ne le justifie
pas pour autant la Cour de cassation
n'admet pas qu'il s'agit d'une
discrimination d'un licenciement
discriminatoire lié à l'état de santé
c'est seulement un licenciement privé de
cause réelle et sérieuse et là
on arrive aux dernières réformes qui ont
été faites par notre président dès qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir les ordonnances
Macron le barème Macron
avec une indemnisation plafonnée
ridicule qui fait que en gros quand on a
pas 5 ans d'ancienneté et qu'on gagne
pas plus de 2000 euros par mois ce qu'il
salaire médian à peu près français ça ne
vaut pas la peine de contester son
licenciement ou presque alors je
caricature un peu mon propos mais c'est
en gros
l'effet absolument voulu d'ailleurs ça a
provoqué un effondrement de l'ordre de
50% dans le cadre des saisines de
conseils de prud'hommes ces ordonnances
donc ça c'est l'inconvénient majeur
parce que la Cour de cassation a une
position très stricte qui est de dire si
il y a pas de désorganisation et pas de
nécessité de remplacement c'est pas une
discrimination alors vous allez me dire
mais pourquoi vous tenez à la
discrimination parce que la
discrimination
elle entraîne la nullité du facilement
ce qui n'est pas la même chose que
l'absence de causerait les sérieuses
donc premièrement elle permet un droit
réintégration
deuxièmement si on demande pas la
réintégration elle permet une
indemnisation qui n'est pas soumise au
plafondonnement du barème Macron donc ça
c'est effectivement
l'inconvénient alors
je
j'évoque maintenant pour terminer si je
puis dire mon mon propos
ce sont c'est la question du parcours
ANPE
oui vous touchez du doigt en votre
qualité de praticien
médicaux ou madame Rio comme fondatrice
de de l'association c'est à dire vous le
droit il est là
il est là depuis 2016 les femmes qui
font un parcours à MP elles ont la même
protection que les femmes enceintes
formidables sauf que depuis quand les
femmes enceintes sont bien traitées dans
des entreprises
depuis quand elle retrouve leur poste en
revenant de grossesse depuis quand c'est
facile pour elle d'annoncer qu'elles
sont enceintes
donc effectivement
c'est pas une question de droit le droit
est là les outils sont là la question
c'est
alors on va panier le fait que il y a en
effet une question de pédagogie
et de connaissances des droites chacun
je vous fais juste une petite remarque
c'est un truc que je dis depuis 40 ans
mais c'est pas grave je suis obstiné
on est tous ou à peu près dans dans ce
pays pas moi mais
les salariés dans l'ensemble le droit du
travail n'est jamais enseigné pendant
toute la scolarité du primaire au
collège en passant par le lycée jamais
vous n'avez un enseignement de droit du
travail
il faut arriver à l'université et
choisir de faire du droit et pour pour
en faire donc effectivement les
connaissances ne sont pas
apportées aux citoyens parce que le
salarié c'est d'abord un citoyen
deuxièmement est-ce qu'on peut mobiliser
ses droits dans l'entreprise quand on
sait que le pouvoir patronal n'est
quasiment plus contestée ni contestable
je vais encore vous parler de la réforme
Macron qui a divisé par deux le nombre
d'élus du personnel le regroupement
délégué du personnel CHSCT comité
d'entreprise a fait perdre 200
poste d'élus du personnel dans toute la
France donc tout à l'heure c'est Madame
Rio qui a dit on a du mal à
obtenir l'assistance des délégués du
personnel des élus du personnel oui on a
du mal parce qu'en plus il y en a deux
fois moins qu'avant
ensuite
pourquoi est-ce que ces droites sont pas
mobilisées cette droite ne sont pas
mobilisées parce que il y a pas de
sanction en vérité il y a pas de
sanction et comme le alors bon j'ai
toujours un peu excessive il faut c'est
mes qualités
et mes défauts
c'est à dire que
avoir toujours la capacité de m'indigner
sur ce qui se passe ça m'aide évidemment
à continuer à travailler dans ce que je
fais sinon j'aurais acheté l'éponge
depuis longtemps mais
quand depuis 40 ans dans ce pays
on cultive l'idée que le code du travail
est un frein au développement des
entreprises est un frein à l'emploi
quand depuis Margaret Thatcher
on nous explique qu'il faut brûler le
code du travail c'était le terme même du
du groupe Monnerville si ma mémoire est
bonne du Medef il faut brûler le code du
travail donc qu'est-ce que ça donne et
bien ça donne que effectivement dans les
entreprises on ne peut pas les femmes ne
peuvent pas mobiliser ses droits parce
que
elles savent intuitivement confusément
de manière
vécue que si elles annoncent qu'elle
partent dans un parcours etc comme
l'humain n'est pas au cœur de la gestion
des entreprises elles risquent en effet
de se faire dégager et elle risque
d'autant plus de se faire dégager que
vous le savez aujourd'hui on est dans la
culture du sous-effectif c'est-à-dire
que tout attention et conviennent pas
nous parler de la grande démission etc
c'est pas le sous-effectif il est pas
lié au désengagement à la grande
émission il est lié à une organisation
délibérée à toutes les restructurations
les réorganisations qui font que
aujourd'hui moi tous les salariés qui
arrivent à mon cabinet qui ont de
l'ancienneté il m'explique avant dans
leur service ils étaient six ils sont
plus que trois et donc ces femmes elles
vont avoir énormément de difficultés à
se prévaloir de leurs droits également
parce qu'elles vont mettre leurs
collègues en difficulté
et que le poser des arrêts de travail
etc c'est presque impossible pour elle
parce que
elles savent qu'elles vont mettre en
difficulté
leurs collègues et donc cette solitude
là elle aussi du renoncement au droit et
je terminerai juste sur la question du
rôle du médecin du travail vous en avez
parlé à plusieurs reprises comme pouvant
être un soutien
alors certainement pas depuis la
dernière réforme
parce que on a prévu un débat
contradictoire avec l'employeur sur les
questions de d'aménagement etc avant
cette réforme le médecin du travail il
faisait son avis
d'aptitudes ou c'est préconisations il
écrivait sur un bulletin etc très bien
l'employeur devait exécuter les
préconisations du médecin du travail je
vous le dis on n'est pas je suis pas en
Utopie
les préconisations des médecins du
travail sont rarement respectées
pourquoi parce que elle crée du souci à
l'employeur qui veut pas aménager les
postes cela si vous voyez le nombre de
de mi-temps thérapeutique par exemple
qui ne trouvent pas de bonnes
organisations parce que l'employeur n'en
veut pas donc il va il va proposer des
des
horaires de travail insupportables
il va mettre des bâtons dans les roues
parce que qu'est-ce qu'il veut
l'employeur veut un salarié qui soit à
200 % au boulot pas à 50 % à 200%. donc
il va pas accepter les aménagements il
va pas respecter les préconisations et
comme le salarié va être de plus en plus
affecté par la situation on va arriver à
quoi ce que veut l'employeur
un avis d'inaptitude qui va conduire au
licenciement donc c'est compliqué et
c'est d'autant plus compliqué que alors
là aussi je vais un peu fustiger la
question de la softlo j'aime bien parler
l'anglais comme ça dans la softlo c'est
je vous ai dit il y a tout dans le code
du travail et on dit ouais on pourrait
faire on peut fêter charte c'est super
sympa on va s'engager etc
on va faire un label
et cette histoire de de la belle
si on si on était dans un monde idéal ma
foi oui formidable les labels sauf que
il faut que vous sachiez mais vraiment
que c'est de la cosmétique c'est à dire
que quand
dans un code du travail il y a tout
et qu'on a besoin de faire une charte à
côté en disant regardez comme je suis
formidable c'est que en réalité alors
d'abord sachez qu'une charte n'a pas de
caractère normatif qu'elle n'est pas
d'application obligatoire et c'est pour
moi alors
peut-être que j'exagère j'ai une vision
aussi déformée par ma pratique ce que
j'appelle le syndrome de la frite McCain
vous vous souvenez de cette publicité si
c'est
les flics mcken c'est ceux qui en
parlent le plus qu'en mange le moins
et bien plus il y a de charte
plus il y a de
moins c'est respecté c'est à dire que
c'est une vitrine
je vais vous dire c'est une vitrine même
pour échapper aux condamnations c'est à
dire que c'est pour dire que si on va en
discrimination sur une affaire prudomale
etc
la main sur le cœur mais moi j'ai la
charte ceci j'ai la Corse là j'ai label
du Schtroumpf je fais tout pour les
femmes vous ne pouvez pas m'accuser de
discriminer regardez tout ce que j'ai
fait et donc effectivement
moi ce que j'aurais plus à dire
et ça y est mon temps est terminé c'est
que il faut mettre le paquet
j'aurais envie de vous dire pour pour
que les droits des femmes avancent
il faut bien sûr que
on revienne sur les ordonnances Macron
qu'on remette des les élus du personnel
qu'on
réinstitue le CHSCT qu'on revienne sur
la réforme de la procédure plus de mal
et y compris de l'appel c'est à dire que
ça si vous voulez que l'intérêt de mon
métier finalement c'est que je vois le
parcours du début jusqu'à la fin et si
vous si l'accès au juge est trop
compliqué parce que le droit il est
toujours en retard c'est ça qu'il faut
savoir toujours toujours en retard et
l'application du droit elle est toujours
très lente donc plus on rend
l'application du droit facile plus on
rend l'accès au juge facile et plus on
fait progresser le droit voilà
et bien merci beaucoup madame pour cette
présentation aussi complète et
d'étonnante peut-être aussi et
importante pour que cette contribution
donc maintenant que les nos cinq invités
se sont exprimés je vais laisser la
parole au rapporteur et en premier lieu
Marie-Pierre Richer en excuse
là on va on va bientôt terminer vous
poser vos questions toutes les
rapporteurs et si d'autres sénatrices
présentent souhaitent poser des
questions on y va parce que Marie-Pierre
doit partir Annick jacquemais à une
question en séance à l'instant donc
Marie-Pierre je te souhaite la parole je
te donne la parole pardon merci mesdames
je te souhaite une bonne question Annick
j'ai aussi une question orale après
Annick mais merci mesdames pour pour vos
interventions qui sont très
enrichissantes madame vous avez parlé
beaucoup du droit moi je dirais quand
même aussi que on se rend compte que la
question sur la santé sexuelle et
reproductive quand on fait le bilan on
reste quand même un tabou avec la peur
de la stigmatisation et on peut parler
droit quand les femmes le vivent que ce
soit un AMP
ou autre bien écoutez le même je ne sais
pas si elles sont toutes connaissance du
droit mais en tout cas je peux vous dire
qu'on en fait on en fait si beaucoup de
femmes qui sont en parcours AMP pose des
congés se débrouillent pour quand c'est
possible pour avoir des rendez-vous en
dehors des horaires le travail c'est pas
toujours le cas donc on peut parler du
droit mais tant que les sujets qui ont
été évoqués ce matin restent des tabous
je pense que ça rend pas service un
parcours un parcours d'AMP c'est 7 ans
c'est très très long minimum ça va
beaucoup plus loin je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la nous sommes pas prêts
non plus hein et que soit les femmes ou
les hommes ne sont pas prêts non plus à
l'évoquer parce que ça stigmatise sa
stigmatise encore madame Madame Valérie
leur bas des planches je suis allée sur
le site de votre de votre fondation et
j'ai vu que vous aviez mis en place une
première journée de formation sur
l'endométriose pour de jeunes internes
donc je sais pas si c'est en 2022 ou si
c'est si c'est récent mais je me dis à
vous écouter qu'on parle des employeurs
on parle des personnes qui sont
concernées mais si au niveau de la
médecine
la formation n'existe pas ou au moins
qu'il n'y a pas de de connaissance
approfondie quid enfin je veux dire pour
moi c'est quand même le premier maillon
de la chaîne avant d'arriver aux
employeurs et et aux personnes qui sont
qui sont concernées donc je vous laisse
déjà avoir un retour sur cette journée
si vous avez constaté effectivement
qu'il y avait il y avait un lourd
déficit j'ai lu aussi récemment que dans
la presse qu'il y avait
l'arrivée d'un autotest concernant
l'endométriose je voudrais savoir où
nous en sommes s'il est commercialisés
en quoi il peut être un premier pas
parce que moi j'ai quand même découvert
avec le sujet sur l'endométriose que ça
touche tellement de douleurs
corporelle je suis pas dans la santé
mais je dirais corporelle qu'une femme
pense peut-être pas tout de suite non
plus l'endométriose donc c'était pour
savoir où nous en sommes et quelle
serait l'apport aussi dans le cadre de
la santé des femmes des femmes et
travail et puis et puis concernant
concernant la ménopause oui
effectivement c'est encore
c'est encore tabou mais je dirais c'est
un tabou du début à la fin de la vie
sexuelle et reproductive des femmes quoi
quand on évoque tous les sujets il reste
malgré tout malgré toute tabou en tout
cas moi je suis je suis contente de vous
avoir entendu pour je crois pour pour la
plupart à dire que le le congé menstruel
était quand même pas la solution et vous
avez parlé de cosmétiques moi je dirais
aussi que c'est un peu du marketing
merci en tout cas mesdames
merci Madame la rapporteur pour
peut-être que tu aies le temps
d'entendre les réponses je vais tout de
suite vous laisser répondre mesdames si
une ou plusieurs souhaiterait prendre
mais j'imagine que Madame
Valérie lorbat des planches était
directement interpellés va apporter des
réponses oui donc très rapidement sur la
journée donc qui était un une expérience
en fait de mise en contact des jeunes
internes avec des patientes en se disant
que ce contact et ce partenariat en fait
un mois ce que je vois c'est qu'il y ait
vraiment une fracture entre les médecins
aujourd'hui notamment sur l'endométriose
et les patientes d'un côté des médecins
finalement qui n'ont pas tellement de
solutions puisqu'en fait on ne connaît
pas bien la maladie et des patientes qui
sont très revendicatives parce qu'elles
ont des parcours extrêmement douloureux
qu'elles n'ont pas été écoutées qu'elles
ont vu plein de professionnels de santé
et que on essaie de réconcilier ça donc
on s'est rendu compte effectivement le
l'endométriose elle est enseignée c'est
la ça a été la troisième rentrée donc
c'est très récent en sixième année de
médecine et là c'est dans la pratique
des internes et on les a mis en
situation en fait et les internes
jouaient des rôles de patientes et des
patientes des rôles de médecins et en
fait c'était intéressant moi ce que j'ai
noté alors c'est c'est qualitatif c'est
pas quantitatif mais j'ai vu chez des
internes junior une
comment dire mise en situation et une
compréhension de la problématique
patiente qui commençait déjà à
s'atténuer chez les internes seniors
avec le professeur qui animait la
session et qui disait mais finalement ça
s'est pas bien passé le l'entretien de
avec la patiente qu'aurait-il fallu
faire et l'interne senior qui disait la
patiente aurait dû parler d'eux et le
professeur rectifié en disant non la
question ça n'est pas ça la question
c'est qu'est-ce que tu aurais pu faire
pour que ça se passe mieux quelle
question tu aurais pu poser donc je
pense qu'il y a voilà juste pour donner
un petit peu je pense qu'au-delà
d'enseigner il y a aussi une pratique
une réconciliation aussi entre les
patients et les médecins voilà juste
pour donner un petit peu une idée et
après je crois que vous aviez une
question
ah oui sur le l'endotest en fait le la
recherche enfin donc ils attendent
aujourd'hui l'équipe qui travaille sur
cette endotest salivaire donc qui est
non invasif attend la confirmation sur
une corde plus importante des premiers
résultats positifs effectivement pour un
diagnostic de l'endométriose extrêmement
facile et certainement pour aller plus
tard dans le futur donc là c'est en
attente de publication des derniers
résultats et je pense qu'il y a eu un
engagement d'ailleurs de François Braun
de prendre en charge le remboursement du
test qui sera pas un test de dépistage
systématique qui rentre vraiment dans
une étape diagnostic il s'agit pas de
passer toutes les adolescents tout le
monde à ce test là mais qui rentrera
dans une approche diagnostique sur
l'endométriose mais qui aidera
énormément oui ce qui a des cas où sur
l'imagerie on a des doutes c'est pas
toujours évident donc ça sera
complémentaire effectivement de la
symptomatologie de de l'imagerie et avec
ce test qui rentrera sur une
caractérisation plus globale de la
maladie
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses donc je
vais laisser la parole aux autres en
rapporteurs éventuellement donc il y
avait Laurence Rossignol je crois qui
voulait intervenir et ensuite Laurence
Cohen
merci Annick merci mesdames c'est les
matinées étaient exceptionnelles
j'imagine même pour vous d'ailleurs
voilà la table ronde aussi permet de se
retrouver
c'est voilà c'est un peu notre rôle
aussi d'organiser ça la
mise en lien des femmes qui travaillent
enfin des femmes parce que bon il se
trouve c'est le réel c'est comme ça
c'est des femmes qui s'intéressent aux
femmes donc je le déplore mais c'est la
vie qui
travaille dans des sujets convergents
moi je faisais passionnant parce que on
est vraiment à mon sens au cœur de
la question féministe c'est à dire qu'on
est à la fois sur
l'invisibilité de la condition des
femmes
le tabou sur la santé sexuelle et
reproductive en fait tout ce qui
concerne l'utérus est répugnant sale et
honteux pour les femmes donc la honte
elle est dans la serre privée mais elle
est démultipliée dans la sphère sociale
et entreprise et enfin sur le l'impact
sur la condition des femmes de la guerre
qui est menée depuis en gros les années
Thatcher vous avez raison de le dater là
contre le salariat et son statut le fait
que les salariés et un statut et donc
tout ça est absolument passionnant j'ai
pas de question pour vous mettre parce
qu'en fait voilà vous avez tout dit j'ai
quelques questions pour les
pour vous trois une qui me préoccupe
c'est quelle est la part de l'âge alors
vous allez me dire j'ai qu'à aller voir
le rapport qui a été remis l'année
dernière environ et je trouve sont
probablement la réponse quelle est la
part de l'âge dans l'infertilité
aujourd'hui
alors mon intuition je pense qu'elle est
majeure
et je pense qu'on a un énorme sujet qui
est là est au croisement justement du
droit du statut salarial et de
l'infertilité que c'est pas normal que
des jeunes femmes ne puissent pas avoir
la sécurité professionnelle suffisante
avant 31 ans pour 30 ans pour engager un
projet de grossesse et que voilà et que
c'est un des indicateurs de la précarité
alors on va la fragilité que les femmes
ressentent dans leur insertion
professionnelle dans leur ce que je peux
me permettre de vous en quelque chose
j'ai découvert toujours dans le cadre de
mes réflexions donc ces formidable que
vous m'aidiez invités que
il y avait une congélation d'ovocytes de
confort qui existe
et que le comité de de bioéthique avec
sagesse à interdit aux employeurs de
financer
c'est congélations de confort puisque
c'est coûteux c'est de l'ordre de 3000
euros
cette précédente Google en fait cette
précédente Google c'est Google qui est
le premier à proposer de financer les
congélation de ces jeunes salariés et
c'est là vraiment on est au cœur de ce
que vous dites c'est-à-dire que
objectivement une femme c'est que si
elle engage un processus de de
grossesse sa carrière va s'arrêter
nous on va sur la 2 minutes nous on a
beaucoup on a beaucoup hésité parce
qu'on l'a on a eu à le voter la
congélation des ovocytes dans la loi
bioéthique et c'était un vrai sujet
compliqué parce qu'on avait d'abord des
jeunes féministes qui considèrent que ça
faisait partie des nouvelles
revendications le droit à la congélation
des ovocytes
donc on est un peu perturbé on voyait
bien l'usage qui pouvait en être fait
pour reporter l'âge de la grossesse chez
les femmes et leur permettre d'être très
performante dans l'entreprise à l'âge où
elles devraient faire des enfants où
elle pourrait faire des enfants pardon
pas de vrai non non mais là auquel on
fait des enfants voilà et on s'est
vraiment été compliqué idéologiquement
d'autant plus qu'être derrière et là
c'est pour vous Madame
madame
une espèce de
romance qui se raconte sur l'AMP ou
quand on entend dire quand vous entend
dire c'est 30% des AMP qui aboutissent
qui finissent par une grossesse et un
enfant
envie de dire aux femmes vous savez vous
allez congeler vos ovocytes mais faut
pas croire qu'après il suffira de les
sortir du congélateur et de mettre en
micro-ondes et que vous aurez un bébé
tout de suite vous allez rentrer dans un
parcours qui est un parcours compliqué
le parcours de réimplantation etc etc et
alors et ça on en parle jamais bref je
tout ça pour donc moi je trouve pas donc
première question infertilité et a et
report de l'âge de la première grossesse
et quel sujet on a nous législateur en
matière accompagnateur de la société
peut aussi prendre le travail deuxième
question c'est sur les traitements
hormonaux de substitution
eu l'impression que je voulais dire si
vous confirmez ça que le fensive qui est
venu des États-Unis ou trollfight que
c'était pas sur les mêmes produits que
ceux qu'on France était une offensive
idéologique contre le droit des femmes à
contourner l'âge afin à limiter les
effets de l'âge et elle a été
dévastatrice dévastatrice qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour dire aux femmes
voilà votre risque de votre risque de de
cancer du sein est infinitésimal comparé
à votre risque de remosthéoporose des
mens Alzheimer etc etc bref voilà donc
comment on peut faire et le nombre de
vos confrères et consœurs qui sont qui
refusent et à une question c'est est-ce
que les 7 ans de traitement que les
gynécos obstétriciens indiquent aux
femmes après faut en fait voilà on vous
le met sous traitement au moment de la
ménopause et puis après à 60 ans en gros
on vous dit ben faut arrêter c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon j'ai toujours eu un
doute sur cette idéologie donc je vous
repose la question je vous pose cette
question là-dessus et merci
merci beaucoup je vais passer
directement là si vous pouvez prendre en
compte les questions en note parce qu'on
va on va comme ça tout le monde entendra
les réponses ce sera plus simple donc la
rapporteur Laurence Cohen et ensuite
notre collègue elle s'achète qui est
souhaitait également intervenir
oui moi je veux vous remercier toutes
mesdames parce que j'ai trouvé cette
cette table ronde extrêmement
passionnante en ce sens où vous êtes
répondu c'est à dire c'était pas
seulement une succession d'intervention
etc ce que on a parfois lors de nos
auditions mais vous êtes répondu et du
coup j'ai trouvé que c'était extrêmement
riche et d'avoir à la fois le regard
des professionnels de santé de madame
qui est donc à l'origine d'une
association qui est très dynamique et
aussi du d'une avocate j'ai trouvé que
c'était extrêmement extrêmement
important d'avoir donc
ces mises en écho moi je suis frappée
par plusieurs choses d'abord le ça va
aller dans le sens de ce que des
questions qui étaient posées par ma
collègue Laurence Rossignol je suis
frappée par quand même à la fois
une formation peut être insuffisante au
niveau des internes euh et donc des des
des médecins qui qui vont être en
exercice
concernant en fait
à la fois d'ailleurs
ce que c'est qu'avoir
être dans un cycle on va dire de
grossesse parce que ça a aussi un lien
avec ce qui se passe au niveau me
semble-t-il de l'entreprise c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un je crois que c'est vous
mettre qui avait dit mais depuis quand
dans une entreprise on se préoccupe
d'une femme enceinte je trouve que ça
c'est vraiment très fort et très
frappant effectivement depuis quand on
s'en préoccupe pas du tout c'est un
problème une femme enceinte dans une
entreprise c'est un problème c'est pas
voilà donc il y a à la fois la formation
des des professionnels on va dire de
santé mais il y a vraiment en même temps
l'information
l'information des des femmes alors pour
la PMC des couples mais aussi par
rapport à la ménopause c'est aussi toute
l'information moi je je suis
complètement là-dessus sur le fait que
les femmes sont dans le noir absolu en
fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne dit pas
donc déjà c'est il y a le poids du
secret et puis c'est comment est-ce
qu'on va être accompagné par un
professionnel de santé parce que vous
avez vous avez tout et son contraire
vous allez discuter avec des amis qui
vont vous dire moi j'ai un traitement et
vous vous n'en avez pas pourquoi vous
n'en avez pas pourquoi elle en a mystère
les symptômes il y en a qui ont des
symptômes qui ont tous les symptômes
madame que vous avez évoqué d'autres qui
ont va qui vont avoir quelques symptômes
et d'autres qui ne vont absolument pas
en avoir mais le fait de ne pas en avoir
c'est super mais est-ce que ça a des
conséquences pas de conséquences de ce
qu'il faudrait quand même un traitement
pas de traitement
mystère et on répond jamais à ces
questions là excusez-moi je suis un peu
peut-être simpliste etc mais c'est
vraiment les questions qu'on se pose et
qu'il est intéressant de voir de voir
aborder sur l'endométriose moi voilà par
exemple on a maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus renseigné etc mais moi je reconnais
aujourd'hui dans cette audition je
n'avais jamais entendu parler par
exemple de lien avec l'alimentation
bon donc découverte et après j'ai été
parce qu'on a un petit un petit objet
très vite j'ai été cliqué dessus et
c'est assez ce qui donne c'est c'est
vraiment cosmétique je veux dire donc
j'aimerais avoir plus la vie d'une
professionnelle enfin moi je trouve très
très important ce qui est ce qui est dit
sur le droit du travail effectivement le
droit au travail a été complètement
détruit au fur et à mesure des des
réformes ça a commencé je m'en excuse
avec elle comme riz qui a quand même
fait fort et après ça a continué à à
tomber et du coup les protections ne
sont pas là et sont de moins en moins de
moins en moins de moins en moins
présente donc c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir quels sont les
pistes que vous nous donnez par rapport
par rapport au jour de carence etc je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
peut j'espère qu'il apparaîtra dans
notre dans nos recommandations parce que
effectivement
il y a pas beaucoup sinon de
possibilités et notamment y compris avec
les protections au niveau des élus du
personnel mais aussi de la médecine du
travail parce que ce que vous avez dit
aussi au niveau de la médecine du
travail c'est que un exercice difficile
avec les nouvelles mesures mais en même
temps une médecine du travail sinistrée
complètement sinistré donc je sais pas
comment les médecins du travail peuvent
intervenir dans ce cas là donc voilà
vraiment un grand grand merci pour votre
apport merci Madame la rapporteur et
donc dernière question ou intervention
de notre collègue elles achètent merci
madame la Présidente alors à mon tour de
vous remercier toutes pour vos
interventions passionnantes ce matin
effectivement extrêmement complémentaire
également dans vos approches de
remercier également la délégation aux
droits des femmes et de remercier les
rapporteurs de mettre sur ce sujet enfin
sur la table ce sujet au combien
important ici au Sénat qui est la
fertilité l'infertilité la ménopause et
effectivement je pense que tout à chacun
aurait à gagner d'écouter cette cette
audition et d'écouter effectivement à la
fois les difficultés mais également la
complexification que cela peut susciter
évidemment dans le cadre du monde du
travail mais également d'un point de vue
psychologique d'un point de vue humain
et cela concerne à la fois effectivement
les femmes au premier chef mais
également les hommes et j'aurais
peut-être souhaité vous entendre sur la
question de la pédagogie ou peut-être de
la non pédagogique qui existe à l'heure
actuelle sur les jeunes générations
parce que je pense que c'est quand même
la clé justement d'un changement de
mentalité et d'un changement aussi de
société si on veut une société plus
bienveillante et qui parle et qui ose
parler de ces sujets encore faut-il que
les jeunes générations connaissent se
saisissent et est conscience d'ailleurs
de de ces problèmes qui peuvent se poser
parce que ça fait quand même peu de
temps qu'on met justement des hauts des
mots m o t sur ces mots M a u x ça fait
quand même peu de temps je trouve qu'on
parle d'endométriose encore moins de
sepk alors que il y a encore un grand
grand nombre de femmes d'ailleurs de
plus en plus qui sont concernés par par
cette grande difficulté et c'est vrai
que j'ai été assez impressionné du
chiffre que Madame Massin vous donniez
sur le nombre d'années alors je crois
que c'est 7,7 vous disiez globalement
d'un parcours PMA et je voulais savoir
comment d'après vous et ce qu'il est
possible de diminuer ces temps alors
vous disiez trois années en fait
d'essais naturelle là on voit aussi le
lien avec l'alimentation la prise de
conscience aussi des femmes à mieux se
connaître à connaître leur corps et là
aussi peu de choses sont enseignées
éduqués justement pour le connaître et
on est un peu et je parle globalement
avec un certain nombre de retours que je
peux avoir autour de moi très livré en
fait à nous-mêmes et il y a quand même
ce sentiment aussi souvent de solitude
qui prédomine ou en tout cas lorsque ça
ne marche pas naturellement de
d'inquiétude sur soi-même ou sur son
parcours donc comment peut-on diminuer
effectivement peut-être ces trois années
décès naturelles que vous avez ok mais
vous avez ok aussi deux années je crois
par rapport à des examens en fait
médicaux qui là aussi sont extrêmement
sans doute très lourd très compliqué
psychologiquement très très difficile
mais qui ont aussi une conséquence bien
évidemment à la fois sur des études sur
un parcours professionnel et donc on
voit c'est bien toute la société qui est
en difficulté et je crois que cette
question au combien essentielle les
d'autant plus à des moments on réfléchit
tous collectivement sur la question de
la natalité dans notre pays de la dém
et on voit bien en fait que c'est les
jeunes femmes ou ces femmes qui sont
dans un parcours on se désire justement
de pouvoir être maman ces hommes de
pouvoir s'inscrire dans un projet de
famille et donc je pense que c'est aussi
une question au combien importante d'un
point de vue plus global de la
démographie et de la natalité je vous
remercie et bien merci donc je vais vous
laisser peut-être vous organiser mais
j'avais vu que Madame Massin souhaitait
intervenir et également Brigitte le
tombe je crois qu'elle se donc ces deux
premières intervenantes pour apporter
des réponses aux rapporteurs et à notre
collègue et le sachent merci pour ces
questions alors je vais d'abord rebondir
sur l'autoconservation des ovocytes
juste pour d'abord remercier le sauna
effectivement d'avoir voté ça et bien
avoir conscience que c'est vrai que si
on met souvent en avant la carrière et
le retard de la conception
de mon expérience aujourd'hui c'est pas
ce qui prime sur la volonté de la
conservation des ovocytes pour les
femmes c'est avant tout leur histoire de
vie personnelle
avec ne pas avoir trouvé le bon conjoint
plein d'autres choses qui jouent et pas
certes la pression du travail certaines
femmes disent clairement que elles
veulent mettre en route leur carrière
avant de pouvoir lancer une maternité
mais il faut pas mes estimer ce qui
n'est pas lié au travail en fait dans ce
souhait d'autoconsommation et c'est
quand même la beauté voilà donc c'est
quand même vraiment une grande avancée
que les femmes aujourd'hui puissent y
avoir accès et bien sûr c'est important
d'en faire la promotion parce que
beaucoup de femmes aujourd'hui ne sont
pas informés de l'existence parce qu'il
y a pas de promotion qui est faite il y
a une difficulté d'accès qui est qui est
réelle en rapport avec l'organisation du
territoire aujourd'hui donc je pense que
information faciliter l'accès et
effectivement rappeler que ce n'est pas
une panacée c'est pas parce qu'on a
conservé ses ovocytes qu'on aura
forcément une grossesse et rien ne
remplace de démarrer un projet de
conception au plus tôt dans dans sa vie
et donc je viens en transition à la
deuxième question qui était celle de
l'impact de l'âge sur les chances de
grossesse il y a un double impact c'est
à dire que plus la femme attend pour son
projet de conception plus Excel pose à
une infertilité qui est liée à au
vieillissement des cellules les ovocytes
sont les cellules reprotiques de la
femme ne sont pas renouvelés ils sont
présents à la naissance et les cellules
vieillissent avec l'âge donc ça va
générer des infertilités qu'on va
considérer inexpliquer en quelque sorte
à ce qu'on va pas trouver d'autres
problèmes autres que les cellules qui
ont vieilli et donc le double impact
vient également du fait que même les
techniques d'assistance médicale à la
procréation fonctionnent nettement moins
bien quand les femmes ont pris de l'âge
parce que justement on a ce problème de
qualité des ovocytes et tout à l'heure
j'ai dit le chiffre de 30% par cycle en
fécondation in vitro ça concerne les
patients qui ont moins de 35 ans à 40
ans ces chiffres ils sont plutôt autour
de 10% et nettement moins encore après
et on voit dans nos centres de
reproduction la proportion des femmes
qui ont dépassé les 38 ans qui
augmentent de manière importante et
encore une fois c'est pas forcément lié
à des problèmes de carrière
professionnelle mais également à des
histoires de vie donc ça c'est très
c'est très important par rapport au
parcours effectivement je pense que là
il y a beaucoup à faire il y a beaucoup
à faire pour diminuer le parcours et
certainement qu'il y a une éducation une
information des professionnels à faire
mais des professionnels de premier
recours un renouvellement aussi parmi la
formation des gynécologues les
gynécologues aujourd'hui qui sont sur le
terrain c'est des gens qui ont été
formés il y a très longtemps et donc il
y a aujourd'hui quand même des
recommandations des informations qui
sont qui sont nouvelles donc il faut
effectivement se tenir informés et donc
les recommandations à l'heure actuelle
c'est passer 35 ans c'est ne pas
attendre un an avant c'était deux ans on
attendait deux ans d'infertilité avant
de dire pouvoir faire des examens etc
vérifier qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
n'était pas normal donc maintenant c'est
passé à un an mais à 6 mois passé 35 ans
pourquoi parce que ce temps perdu
d'essai sans efficacité c'est autant de
longueur de parcours ensuite qui qui
s'additionne donc déjà cette information
là donc auprès des professionnels et
auprès des professionnels de premier
recours surtout les médecins
généralistes les sages-femmes parce que
c'est cela qui sont en contact direct et
le médecin du travail aussi là peut
avoir son rôle à jouer dans ce cadre
dans la puisqu'il a perdu d'autres
d'autres voilà donc voilà donc ça c'est
important réduire le parcours avant ce
temps d'infertilité qui va être exigé
avant qu'on puisse avoir accès et
pourquoi pas donc nous à Créteil on a
mis en place un bilan de fertilité un
fertilité de check-up c'est à dire
pourquoi attendre l'infertilité avant de
se rendre compte qu'il y a un problème
pour procréer aujourd'hui on a les
moyens avec des examens simples de
s'assurer que tout va bien on fait on le
fait pour les bilans cardiovasculaires
on a on peut le faire également pour la
fertilité de s'assurer que tout va bien
et avoir les bons conseils pour donner
le maximum de chances de conception dès
le projet de celui-ci sans attendre de
se retrouver en échec dans ce cas c'est
vraiment très important ensuite pour le
bilan c'est un peu la même chose
c'est-à-dire ces deux d'exploration on
pourrait les réduire avec des
organisations professionnelles un peu
différentes comme j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire mettre voilà aller
plutôt directement sur des endroits
spécialisés avec un bilan complet en une
fois et pour la femme et pour l'homme et
un compte rendu qui permet de prendre
action très rapidement pour expliquer
les traitements qui peuvent être
proposés et leurs chances de réussite et
puis sur votre dernière question sur la
pédagogie face aux nouvelles générations
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué parce
que donc je fais partie d'un collectif
protège ta fertilité auquel le collectif
bande participe avec Madame Rio et
l'objectif c'est d'éduquer les jeunes de
18 à 25 ans sur justement tout ce qui
est physiologie de la reproduction etc
et donc on a fait ça sur insta parce que
il faut parler dans le canal des jeunes
aujourd'hui et on s'est retrouvé quand
même face à des remarques qui étaient du
genre mais on est trop nombreux sur
terre donc tous ces démarches
écologiques et effectivement un recul
des jeunes générations sur le projet de
maternité pour des raisons écologiques
d'une part et d'autre part également
pour des régions des raisons peut-être
plus féministes personnelles
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui de vouloir
sortir de
voilà mettre la femme dans un projet de
maternité obligatoire aujourd'hui on a
des générations qui veulent sortir de ça
et qui veulent prendre le temps de faire
un choix d'avoir une maternité et pas de
se sentir obligé d'avoir une pression
sociale sur la maternité donc il faut
faire extrêmement attention sur la façon
dont on apporte l'information moi je
suis persuadée que plus les gens sont
informés mieux ils font leur choix mais
il faut pas qu'ils se sentent obligés
d'accéder à une maternité très
précocement quand c'est pas leur choix
de vie donc c'est très important et il
faut rappeler et ça a été rappelé dans
le plan national fertilité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas alors cette
notion de on est trop nombreux dans le
monde persiste mais il y a une baisse
mondiale de la natalité et c'est
vraiment une préoccupation on le voit
vraiment en Europe c'est franc mais
c'est pas que en Europe et dans les pays
à mural c'est également dans les pays en
voie de développement donc notre
population est en voie de diminution et
donc c'est vraiment très important
d'appuyer sur ces sujets là que les
maternités qui sont désirées et choisis
on puisse faire en sorte qu'elles
arrivent le plus facilement le plus
rapidement possible avec le nombre
d'enfants qui est souhaité puisqu'il
faut bien prendre en considération
aujourd'hui qui a certainement une
partie des femmes qui va décider ça ne
sera plus tabou de ne pas avoir
d'enfants
merci
alors pour ce qui est de la ménopause
donc bien sûr le traitement hormonal il
a beaucoup beaucoup souffert de cette
étude américaine qui était une étude en
fait de prévention primaire
cardiovasculaire et c'est vrai que la
population choisisse une population
âgée avec une moyenne d'âge de 63 ans
20% des femmes avaient plus de 70 ans
donc avec un gap de 15 ans depuis leur
ménopause et on leur a donné un
traitement par voie orale et un projet
statique de synthèse qu'on utilise pas
en France et donc les conclusions de
cette étude alors que on le donnait en
prévention cardiovasculaire parce qu'il
faut savoir que la mortalité féminine
c'est 35% cardiovasculaires 4% le cancer
du sein et donc surtout chez les
américaines on s'était dit les
oestrogènes c'est bon pour les artères
la tension tout ce que je vous ai dit
donc si on donne des oestrogènes on va
les protéger à l'inverse quand une femme
a une interromatose installée ce que la
carence oestrogénique va favoriser et là
ces femmes là elle n'avaient pas été
traitée depuis 10 ans elles avaient donc
une athéromatose installé ça prend les
matériels et le fait de leur donner un
traitement par voie orale à créer des
accidents cardio-vasculaires à créer des
embolies pulmonaires à créer des
infarctus des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux alors que c'était exactement
ce qu'on voulait éviter donc ça a été
vraiment un tsunami international pour
ce qui est du risque de cancer du sein
on a rien appris avec la whe on savait
qu'il y a une petite augmentation du
risque qui est à 1,3 qui correspond moi
je dis toujours le ce petit risque pour
ces traitements la pas le traitement à
la française on y reviendra pour ces
traitements-là c'est l'équivalent d'une
femme qui est en poids normal par qui
est en surpoids par rapport à une femme
normale une femme qui fait du sport par
rapport à une femme qui est sédentaire
une femme qui fume par rapport à une
femme qui ne fume pas une femme qui boit
de l'alcool par rapport à une femme qui
ne boit pas ce petit 1,3 c'est ça sur le
risque de cancer du sein donc je ne dis
pas qu'il existe pas avec ces
traitements là mais c'est très peu de
choses puisque ça correspond à deux
cancer du sein en plus sur cinq ans sur
1000 femmes alors que sur 1000 femmes
sur cinq ans avec le risque aujourd'hui
de 1 sur 8 vous savez que le risque de
cancer du sein c'est un sur 8 c'est 50
femmes c'est-à-dire que vous avez 50
femmes sur 1000 qui vont faire dans les
5 ans un cancer du sein de toute façon
et si vous donnez un traitement hormonal
le traitement à l'américaine vous en
aurez deux de plus et vous en aurez six
de plus au bout de 10 ans par contre en
France on utilise le traitement à la
française qui commence à vraiment et
s'aimer sur le plan européen et même
chez les Américains on utilise nous de
l'estradiol donc exactement la même
molécule que ce que sécrétait les
ovaires avant leur arrêt de
fonctionnement et de la progestérone
micronisée et avec cela on a une étude
européenne qui s'appelle epic qui montre
qu'au bout de 8 ans il n'y a pas de
différence de risque de cancer du sein
avec ce traitement là et la voie
transgermique est vite les accidents
trop bons emboliques donc il est évident
qu'avec le traitement à la française on
pas du tout les mêmes risques avec les
traitements américains en plus quand on
voit les résultats de la WHI qui ont été
d'abord donné de façon brutale et qui
ont vraiment arrêté toutes les
prescriptions dans le monde entier
quatre ans plus tard ils nous ont donné
les résultats en fonction des tranches
de vie des femmes donc ils avaient une
petite partie des femmes entre 50 et 60
ans une partie des femmes entre 60 et 70
et je vous ai dit des femmes de plus de
70 ans il y avait très peu de femmes
entre 50 et 60 ans pourquoi puisque
c'était la première étude randomisée
randomisée c'est à dire qu'à certaines
femmes en donnent un traitement efficace
à d'autres on donne un placebo
évidemment entre 50 et 60 ans je vous ai
dit il y a quand même beaucoup de
symptômes donc il y avait très peu de
femmes qui pouvaient entrer dans dans
cette étude puisqu'elle n'avait pas de
symptômes mais quand même quand on
regarde ces femmes entre 50 et 60 ans
même au moment de la publication elles
avaient moins de risques
cardiovasculaires et 18 ans après ils
nous ont montré donc les résultats ces
femmes sont toujours suivies il y a une
diminution morbi mortalité
cardiovasculaire et de toute la
mortalité chez les femmes qui ont été
traitées entre 50 et 60 ce qui fait que
toutes les recommandations aujourd'hui
internationales et le dernier congrès à
Lisbonne en 2022 rappelle et même les
Américains la Nams a modifié ses
recommandations et je vous les avez
donné je crois en en
document pour nous dire que le
traitement hormonal de ménopause un bal
une balance bénéfice risque positive
entre 50 et 60 ans dans les 10 premières
années
et après vous me parliez du temps de
traitement alors ça c'est les
recommandations internationales il faut
que vous sachiez qu'en France quand même
nos recommandations la chaise la
dernière fois qu'elles ont été publiées
ces 2014 et que depuis il y a énormément
de choses qui ont changé donc le temps
de traitement donc je vous ai dit qu'on
avait fait des recommandations pour la
pratique clinique c'est à dire qu'on
reprend toutes les recommandations pour
la pratique link c'est deux gens de
travail on reprend toute la
bibliographie internationale pour
répondre à des questions et donc CRPC
ont été publié en 2021 et justement le
temps de traitement il n'y a pas de
recommandations de temps de traitement
tout dépend pourquoi vous le donnez et
bien sûr tous les ans il faut évaluer la
balance bénéficie en fonction de
l'histoire familiale en fonction de son
histoire personnelle en fonction de
l'état de santé ou on se trouve le
traitement hormonal peut devoir être
arrêté pour telle route telle raison
mais peut être poursuivi à partir du
moment où par exemple c'est une
symptomatologie climatérique qui
persiste encore à l'arrêt ou par exemple
une fragilité
osseuse que l'on veut éviter donc on
peut très bien continuer à traiter les
femmes ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir une vraie évaluation annuelle de
son traitement mais il n'y a pas de
recommandation d'arrêt de traitement ni
5 ans ni sept ans ni quoi que ce soit ça
n'est écrit
nulle part si quelqu'un vous a dit ça il
faut qu'il vous la prouve je sais mais
c'est faux c'est totalement faux et en
tout cas dans ne recommandations
franco-française c'est bien écrit qu'il
n'y a pas de délai et qu'on ne peut tout
dépendre de la balance bénéficier risque
au tenter ensuite je sais plus oui je
pense que c'est vraiment important que
les femmes toutes les femmes soient
informées alors pour être informé bon je
pense qu'il faut passer par le sociétal
tout ce qu'on essaie de faire mais la
consultation de 45 ans est vraiment le
moment idéal parce que la périménopause
dont je vous ai parlé c'est à peu près
trois ans trois quatre ans avant la
ménopause et 51 ans donc à 45 ans peu de
femmes ont déjà des signes mais bon pour
certaines ça peut être le cas et en tout
cas il est possible dans cette
consultation là de dire vous savez la
ménopause va arriver à peu près dans la
cinquantaine vous pourriez ressentir tel
n'hésitez pas à consulter sachez que si
vous présentez cette symptomatologie ça
peut être le début de quelque chose
pour qu'elle soit pas angoissée moi je
vois énormément de femmes qui disent
mais je ne me reconnaissais plus je me
suis mis en arrêt de travail parce que
j'étais plus je savais pas et je pensais
que j'étais en train de démarrer une
dépression et j'ai même des femmes qui
sont qui ont été mises sous
anti-dépresseur en arrêt de travail soit
antidépresseur pour des dépressions qui
ne sont pas des dépressions donc il faut
informer les femmes et dans cette
consultation il faut informer du risque
climatérique donc ces symptômes mais
informer aussi des risques
cardiovasculaires
osseux carcinologiques voire neuro
cognitif parce que en fonction de son
histoire familiale en fonction de son
histoire personnelle et notamment de son
hygiène de vie il y a énormément de
choses qui peuvent être prévenues
commencez que la carence œstrogénique va
multiplier par deux le risque de diabète
si cette femme elle a déjà une petite
insuline non résistance il faut la
prévenir il faut lui dire
cancer tous les cancers
là en fonction de votre histoire
familiale vous pouvez avoir plus de
risques de telle ou tel cancer donc une
prévention qui va être plus serrée donc
c'est important qu'on fasse le tri des
femmes qui méritent une surveillance
classique type mammographie tous les
deux ans voire une surveillance
spécifique risque de cancer du colon par
exemple il y a des femmes qui n'en
parlent pas je crois que c'est vraiment
important qu'on évalue à la fois le
risque cardiovasculaire le risque osseux
parce que si on si une femme n'a pas de
symptomatologie qu'elle se dit beaucoup
du moins le traitement mon âge j'en ai
pas besoin en plus je n'ai pas très
envie et qu'elle a des facteurs de
risque c'est important de faire au moins
un bilan osseux et c'est assez simple à
densitométrie minérale osseuse ça n'est
plus prescrit pourquoi alors ce que l'on
dit c'est que c'est parce que c'est pas
remboursé mais ça coûtait carrément de
la plupart des mutuelles le prennent en
charge mais le problème c'est que si
vous prescrivez en tant que médecin
généraliste une densitométrie et que
cette densité montre un os un peu
fragile ça va mener à quoi
à la nécessité d'une prescription et la
nécessité d'une prescription et c'est
pour ça que le traitement Monal est très
peu prescrit ça nécessite une
consultation spécifique dédiée par un
professionnel qui connaît vraiment bien
le sujet et qui puisse répondre à toutes
les questions des femmes qui puisse
évaluer la balance bénéficerie et c'est
pour ça que sur le site de la Société
Nationale Française de ménopause de
gemmie il y a cette brochure
d'informations sur la balance bénéficier
risque du traitement hormonal parce que
vraiment ça nécessite que les femmes
avant de mettre en place un traitement
hormonal les un bilan complet c'est sûr
mais qu'elles aient pu lire justement
tout cela qu'on puisse parler du risque
de cancer du sein qu'on puisse parler de
risques cardiovasculaire du risque et
c'est pas une consultation c'est souvent
20 minutes une consultation dédiée à la
ménopause 20 minutes c'est pas suffisant
donc il faut davantage il faut surtout
que cette femme puisse repartir de la
consultation lire s'informer revenir et
qu'on puisse reprendre lui réexpliquer
la balance bénéfice l'intérêt ou le non
l'intérêt d'un traitement et si on ne
peut pas lui donner un traitement parce
qu'elle a des contre-indications la
compagnie il y a des thérapeutiques il y
a des accompagnements autres qui font
que cette femme puisse être aidée donc
cette consultation de 45 ans pour moi
elle est importante enfin je pense
qu'elle va être mise en place mais ce
qui est important c'est que ce soit fait
pour les femmes par des spécialistes de
la ménopause
merci beaucoup pour ces deux réponses
qui souhaitaient apporter des réponses à
nos collègues rapporteurs en complément
de ce qui vient dit oui maître oui alors
c'est pas une en fait c'est pas une
réponse c'est une idée qui m'est venue
en cours et que j'ai pas évoqué qui est
juste que bien sûr tout ce qu'on va vous
opposer dans toutes les démarches que
vous ferez c'est que ça va accentuer la
discrimination à l'égard des femmes et
que ça évidemment ça ne peut pas être un
argument
c'est à dire que c'est que c'est un peu
le le
principe du de la date selon lequel nul
ne peut se prévaloir de sa propre
turpitude c'est-à-dire que pas dire ah
ben non déjà qu'on discrimine qu'on a du
mal à embaucher les nanas si en plus
vouloir donner des droits
supplémentaires on va être obligé de
continuer donc parce que c'est ça que ça
veut dire donc voilà mais ça vous le
saviez déjà bien sûr
merci beaucoup donc en visio en visio
peut-être d'abord je vais passer la
parole parce que Madame Virginie Riot
réclamait la parole et puis après on
reviendra à vous madame oui je vous
remercie alors c'est vrai que là on est
en train de parler de choses qui sont
qui doivent s'inscrire dans un vrai
changement de manière de penser de
manière de penser la la femme la place
de la femme la santé de la femme nous
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire depuis 10
ans sur la question de la fertilité
l'infertilité et l'AMP et je dois dire
que les
questions enfin que les choses avancent
très lentement parce qu'évidemment il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de résistance donc
c'est vraiment intéressant que les
femmes se rassemblent donc les alliés
des femmes se rassemblent et mettent en
oeuvre des choses pour apporter des
idées nouvelles parce que là en fait on
se rend compte qu'on est on est en train
de gérer des idées d'une autre époque
mais on s'est quand même la réalité nous
en ce qui concerne la fertilité
l'infertilité et notamment la question
des jeunes
je voudrais quand même rappeler que dans
le rapport sur les causes d'infertilité
il y a différents axes de travail et les
deux premiers sont formation
sensibilisation des plus jeunes de façon
individuelle avec plein tout un tas de
recommandations mais aussi de façon
collective avec là aussi tout un tas de
recommandations et le troisième axe
c'est la formation et l'information des
professionnels du soin de première qui
soit sage-femme médecin généraliste
médecin scolaire
les recommandations sont là c'est le
même discours que tout à l'heure quand
je vous expliquais que le droit du
travail il est là et que les choses sont
là il faut juste qu'on les mette en
oeuvre là c'est pareil il y a tout un
tas de recommandations pour faire ce
changement de représentation sur
qu'est-ce que c'est que la fertilité
qu'est-ce qui impacte la fertilité
comment je peux protéger ma fertilité
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'AMP parce que
on est en train on gère là et on a
discuté aujourd'hui de des préjugés des
idées reçues qui persistent malgré le
travail qu'on fait malgré les petites
évolutions et il faut absolument que la
société
prenne conscience que ensemble on pourra
mettre des choses en place mais que si
chacun résiste de son côté on va vers la
une catastrophe il y a bon alors il y a
presque c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
pas faut pas tomber dans dans le
paternalisme il faut pas tomber non plus
d'en faire peur à tout le monde donc il
y a une vraie nécessité de penser
comment on va apporter ces idées
nouvelles pour qu'elle puisse infuser
dans l'ensemble de la société
merci beaucoup pour ces compléments de
réponse et puis peut-être sur
l'alimentation puisque c'est vrai
qu'avec ma voisine rapporteur Laurence
Cohen du coup ce questionnait mais comme
le disait la rapporteur c'est vrai que
ce qui est indiqué sur la consultation
rapide qu'elle a pu faire était assez
somme toute basique manger des fruits et
légumes pas trop salé pas trop sucré et
plat préparé donc ça nous paraissait à
la base d'une hygiène de vie à peu près
a priori classique
[Musique]
de toute façon oui une hygiène de vie
classique je pense que c'est important
en fait
l'endométriose est une maladie on parle
toujours de maladies gynécologique mais
c'est une maladie inflammatoire
systémique donc on connaît encore très
mal les mécanismes mais ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il y a énormément de molécules
pro-inflammatoires qui sont produites et
donc en fait l'idée c'est vraiment une
alimentation de type anti-inflammatoire
donc qui favorise tout ce qui peut être
anti-inflammatoire les matières gras
insaturées effectivement les fruits et
légumes et qui évitent tout ce qui peut
être pro-inflammatoire donc plutôt les
viandes rouges l'excès en protéines
et alors après jusqu'à potentiellement
et alors là je me prononcerai pas parce
que je pense qu'au niveau scientifique
et médical on n'a pas de de support
là-dessus mais les femmes qui pratiquent
ce type d'alimentation disent qu'elles
sont soulagées tout ce qui est éviter ou
limité le glucket le gluten
potentiellement les produits laitiers
moi je viens du monde des produits
laitiers j'ai toujours du mal à dire ça
surtout pour des femmes voilà je pense
que c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
mais en tout cas je pense que
sans être excessif en tout cas les
femmes qui alors ça dépend d'où elles
viennent aussi si elles viennent d'une
alimentation très transformée et
qu'elles améliorent forcément ça va
améliorer leur symptômes en tout cas
c'est quand même du bon sens même si
c'est vraiment limité tout ce qui est
pro-inflammatoire et augmenter tout ce
qui est anti-inflammatoire donc je pense
que c'est un peu ça la base et apprendre
aux patientes à manger et au-delà de ça
il y a un autre aspect qui est que en
fait 80% des femmes qui ont
l'endométriose ont aussi ce qu'on
appelle un symptôme de l'intestin
irritable donc il y a un vrai alors
probablement en lien avec ce territoire
inflammatoire avec le microbiote mais en
tout cas agir aussi sur la consommation
de fibres enfin voilà tout ce qui peut
aller dans ce sens là peut améliorer
aussi les symptômes digestifs et les
douleurs voilà
et bien écoutez à vous souhaitiez pardon
alors madame Massin avait d'abord
demandé pardon et je reviendrai avec
vous ensuite madame oui pardon c'était
juste pour ajouter un mot par rapport à
l'alimentation et la fertilité ça joue
bien et c'est démontré chez l'homme sur
la qualité des spermatozoïdes le régime
steak frites c'est le c'est le pire et
donc il faut passer plutôt au régime
végétarien voilà ou en tout cas peu de
protéines
de viande de viande rouge et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est clairement démontré sur
la fertilité
alors juste rapidement en fait il y a
quelque chose aussi qui est très
important c'est les questions liées à la
santé environnementale nous enfin notre
association on est membre d'une
association qui travaille beaucoup sur
ces sujets de santé environnementale et
qui défend
le sujet de faire de la santé
environnementale un des piliers
principaux de la sécurité sociale
pour que ce sujet sentait
environnemental qui impacte directement
à la fois l'alimentation
les cosmétiques les produits chimiques
qui nous environnent et qui impactent la
santé humaine de façon globale que ça
soit la fertilité certaines maladies
chroniques qui explosent du fait de la
de notre imprégnation massive à tous par
rapport à tous les perturbateurs
endocriniens qui nous enverront ce sujet
là aussi c'est un sujet qui existe
depuis plus de 60 ans et qui a comme les
sujets qu'on vient d'évoquer santé de la
femme femme et tout ça a du mal à
exister
à être pris en considération ration par
la société alors que c'est pour nous un
sujet essentiel et qui regroupe tout ce
qu'on vient de dire avant
et bien écoutez mesdames merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation merci pour
cette présentation à 5 voix qui vous
présentation étaient extrêmement
qualitatives et aussi nous a apporté des
réponses à certaines thématiques et
comme le disait les rapporteurs et les
Elsa notamment c'est vrai que ça a été
intéressant aussi de vous entendre
partager des avis aussi ou des solutions
qui pouvaient être différentes et c'est
tout l'intérêt l'intérêt pardon de ces
tables rondes donc merci on reviendra
peut-être vers vous si vous avez
d'autres éléments à nous communiquer par
mail ou par d'autres voix nous sommes
évidemment intéressés mais vraiment
merci pour la qualité de ces débat ce
matin puisque nous avons presque fait
trois heures de table ronde ce qui est
quand même intéressant vu le peu de
d'intervenants vous étiez cinq et on
était assez peu nombreuses comme vous
l'avez souligné mettre mais je ne doute
pas que nos collègues sénateurs
prendront en connaissance
des comptes rendus et de cette vision
par
ultérieurement donc merci vraiment et
puis merci à mesdames les rapporteurs
pour les questions pertinentes les
remarques qu'elles ont pu vous faire
belle journée à tous et à toutes surtout